Let me get this straight, right? You're coming in here. Dude,
you are such a disgusting, [music] wretched piece of Lyle convoys,
it's unbelievable.
You you little
Shut the [__] up, you pathetic
Okay. It's going to be okay, man. It's going to be okay. total
loser
Okay. You will lie No child you crash with us. Okay. [music]
Okay. Finally, yes.
This is what I was saying. This is the thing you should actually
get angry
Okay. So, Chud covers how we I don't think we have anybody here
right now
who is unaware of where the Aiden drama was at as of yesterday,
right? Are you unaware of the Aiden underground drama? Do I need
to do a quick recap for
Is there anybody here? Just put a one in the chat if you're unaware
entirely. Shikone here Iro.
Shikone Iro.
Couple people who are unaware. Essentially, if you guys know
who Aiden is, Aiden's the YouTuber, okay?
Aiden's like a former commentary YouTuber turned streamer who
likes debating, big Destiny fan for a long
He got into some drama in the UK at a commentary YouTuber meetup.
He basically was getting mocked for being super like antisocial,
super weird. After being mocked for this, he
he got kind of drunk and he ended up with a with a guy he like
covers extensively, guy he A-logs extensively. He like started
posting the doxx information of that guy's wife in his Discord
while drunk, okay? And he was doing it and then he got into a
VC and he also was drunk and talking about like pretty unhinged
about this guy's wife. Now, I think that was like a VC that he,
while not private, he didn't expect it to like go wide. And so,
his comments are like jokes while you're drunk with like your
friends. And while incredibly cringe, I do not think are are
terribly serious.
I don't take them terribly seriously. I I think you have to take
into account that it's like that's leaked. Like he's acting a
certain way because it's supposed to be a close setting. Not
a not a private setting, but like a smaller group of people,
right?
So, he makes all these comments and then he gets in drama with
his friends more and more and they eventually accuse him of they
say you were doxxing this person. It becomes more public and
I think because of the personal life drama that's going on, people
calling him a weirdo, people making fun of it also gets leaked
that he has a crush on a girl he's done content on. Um and after
all of this stuff,
No, no, no. He actually doxx this woman though. Yeah, drunk doxxing.
So, he's getting crucified this bad over drunk doxxing in a group
comments. Yeah, but drunk doxxing is bad and Aiden has said it's
bad. Right? Like like the doxxing is really bad. It's it's like
really bad. Like on it's bordering on unforgivable. It's
it's bad.
But the comments to me, while speaking to his mindset that he
is like fairly deranged towards this guy,
I do think it's fairly deranged that he did this. Yes, Aiden
did do leak.
Who leaked it though? Well, it's a 100-person private chat and
100 people have access to the VC as far as I know.
So, like it's not really private. I'm saying it's a close setting,
it's not a private setting, okay?
And I think with regards to those jokes, I don't take them that
seriously. I don't think they're serious. I think Chud There's
an argument on Chud's side and I get it.
So, Chud argues Chud is going to argue. Wait, did I finish the
summary though? So, basically he's got like a personal life drama
going on and this doxxing drama at the same time and he's getting
criticized over both. And what I think happened was the personal
drama hurt his ego bad enough that he decided to stand on business
with the doxxing drama and say one that it was fake, two that
it's not that bad and three I did it and I feel bad now. Like
he sort of probably the worst criticism I have of Aiden is that
Aiden's opinions seemed to change over time as he became more
and more by the facts that were leaked, okay? So, basically like
when there were no facts out about this, when there was no recording
and nobody was on the record saying like what Aiden was talking
about, he was like no, it was like fake. Part of the information
was fake. It's not even a doxx. It's it's available in other
places. He was explaining how he's like totally okay doing this,
right? And then a little more information came out and he's like
I I had no idea any of that was true or something. And then a
little more information comes out and he like eventually this
call gets leaked and he's like actually, I'm sorry I did it.
It was up. And it's like that change over time, that's probably
what to me is the most criticizable in terms of Aiden's like
character.
I think a lot of the other stuff's
not understandable or defensible, but it's like it's just bad.
It's mistakes that he could have toned for.
The other stuff's like character stuff that I don't think changes
necessarily is very concerning, right?
Um and Aiden is the kind kind of guy that he's going to make
this go even worse for himself because what Aiden can't do is
admit when he's wrong at all. So, like Aiden Aiden is doing again,
I'm going to say it, the tomfoolery thing, okay? Where Aiden
did something that you could get out of, that wasn't that bad.
It was like kind of annoying, but he got so he he decided to
be so driven by his ego that he would refuse to admit any wrongdoing
for a long time and then then he'll admit wrongdoing at the start
of a conversation and and basically through his consistent arguing
appear to take it
right? So, he will consistently argue argue argue argue argue
argue and it feels like he's taking it back in those situations.
That is uncalled for. I doubt he's displayed even half the fairness
of Tom.
Well, that's not false. That's not terribly false, okay? It's
not not obviously false. Now,
when Chud reviewed this, he reviews the
I think he so always too hard about the call, but I do get it
that I think from like a total normie perspective, the things
being said in that call are insane. I just think for me,
it's Chud logic.
Like it's it's Chud logic.
Like Chud logic, you'll you'll see Chud logic gets really mad
about a comment Aiden makes about
Lyle convoys wife. He says we're going to go we're going to have
a gang bang with Lyle convoys wife. Oh, we will we actually have
an adjacent thing to to point out there. There's another there's
another argument that maps onto this one-to-one, which is very
interesting to me cuz I think people's opinions would change.
Give me a sec. Trying to get hydrated enough for the stream here.
and it's like do you guys remember when Sneako accused Brandon
Buckingham of wanting to his girlfriend? It's actually a one-to-one
match of that scenario. So, how did you feel when Sneako said
that Brandon Buckingham said he was going to his girlfriend?
Brandon Buckingham said Sneako went on Twitter and said this
coming from the guy who like threatened to my girlfriend in response
to something Brandon Buckingham was saying or he might have said
it on the stream, I can't remember. But it is the exact exact
same argument. So, I just find it weird. The argument is I'm
calling your girlfriend or your wife a a poof. Everybody but
you. Your wife is a We're all going to go there and we're all
going to gang bang your wife because she's a Okay? It's like
that's the joke. Is your wife wants us all to gang bang her.
And then people are like but really would would the wife actually
consent to you all fighting to her? If not, if you don't think
she literally consent in real life, then that's a real threat.
And it's like no, I am I am saying that your wife is a What did
BB say? Anyone remember? Brandon Buckingham said to Sneako that
we're all going to go over to your place and run a train on your
girlfriend. But like that the whole idea there it it is a one-to-one.
The whole idea is Sneako, you're a your girlfriend is a We're
all going to go your girlfriend in front of you. And so, no no
no no, Ryle, you're you're you're considering these things the
same. Um it doesn't change that. No no no, it's it's like it's
literally not um Yeah, sorry. Yeah, you're confused about what
I'm arguing right now. Um So, I'm saying with regards to that,
I don't think Aiden was actually saying like
I don't think he was.
Now, realistically,
that's totally irrelevant in like the actual problems people
are having with Aiden right now, okay? It's actually totally
irrelevant because
that comment realistically, nobody's canceling him over that
comment, okay? I'm just I'm going to give Aiden that. I'll give
him that one thing, okay? And I'll just say it without argument
that I don't think he he did the right thing. Because that's
going to turn into an argument for him and I I don't care to
actually have that argument anywhere, to be honest. I'm just
laying out that I do think that kind of got kind of got swept
in there. What's the actual problem? Aiden is still
Uh no. The Oh, the actual problem is
uh he got way too emotional and deranged about this guy
and he did something that is obviously over the line by his own
personal set of
And then when he got called out for
he decided he was going to ego check. He's going to like do an
a total ego check on people, right? Just trying to like debate
them out of thinking that. And it's like no, it's transparently
one thing that hasn't been brought up with Aiden is he basically
said he didn't want to argue using WillyMac's wife as an example
when he did multiple instances of content about WillyMac's wife,
He covered the WillyMac video, he covered all of that stuff and
he said I'm unfamiliar with that situation. He wasn't unfamiliar,
right? He's been I think he's just been lying about a bunch of
this
and again, it it looks quite bad. Looks quite quite bad.
I got to get to the dick or stuff >> So, why the [__]
would I think, oh, he won't take a step forward? I think it's
very possible that he would take a step forward. I think it's
very possible that he would call Lyle convoys wife. I would have
thought that he would do this to
You notice the change change in tone with Aiden from Dickers
to Chud. Um yeah, and then and then Chud tried to argue with
Dickers that
it actually didn't have anything to do with like the social like
ladder that Aiden climbs.
And I'm like, bro, I couldn't disagree any more strongly on that
one either. I think I think Chud tries to get Aiden to agree
when he joins the call and Aiden does agree. Aiden's like, no,
I respect Dickers. I would totally have taken
Off, man.
But we'll listen to Chud make this criticism. Dickers responds
in the chat says, I'm awake. Aiden wasn't drinking on his own.
I was getting drunk, too. I forget how crazy the jokes were here.
I forgot how crazy the jokes were here.
I don't think this is true. Okay, I I don't think this is true.
I and I I don't want to Dickers further,
But I do think I do think that he's saying I forgot how how crazy
the jokes I know that before Chud broke reviews this, Dickers
reviewed that like part of this call. Oh, no, he didn't. He cut
it off. Maybe not.
I thought he reviewed the leaks before, but maybe not.
Anyway, this after I already blew up on Aiden to get him to stop
spamming docs. I'm just happy he's moved on to being Oh, well,
maybe maybe he freaked out on Aiden like actually posting the
docs. And now he's like, okay, I got in a different situation.
Yeah, I don't think this gets illustrated well. Anyway, without
further ado, we'll get to the >> Accept that I'm correct
and it will be a lot easier, bro, okay? Either you hop on and
I can explain to you Give him a second. and I can explain to
you why you're wrong or just accept that I'm right now. Which
is it going to be? Either cuz I need to focus on this and I don't
want to waste time talking to you, okay?
Either accept in chat now that I'm correct or hop in the call.
We can spend 10 minutes talking about it and then you'll agree
at the end that I'm correct. Which is it going to be?
Which is it going to be?
Which is it going to be? I'm going to continue until you answer.
Okay, we we listened to these leaked calls yesterday.
Well, I think these leaked calls um they do point to a a mentality
from Aiden that is diseased, right? That he's like talking about
like how much up [__] he's going to do to this guy
cuz this guy won't talk to him.
I think I think that's wild. That's like a wild standard to talk
about like how you're going to continue to try to ruin this guy's
life until he talks to you, right? I do think that's a wild standard
to have. I do think all of the commentary that he's doing here
is just hyperbolic. He's like performing for some
totally degenerate
like his his own sycophants, right? He's just doing this to like
I I think ego bomb after the previous couple days. Like soothe
soothe his own ego after the past couple days, all right? Anyway,
I'm chill. I'm fine. Just as long as he isn't like advocating
for actual I'm chill. I'm fine as long as he isn't advocating
for perpetual I don't have time for this, Dickers, but I'm going
to make it simple, okay? I don't give a [__] how
drunk you are. There's a bunch of shits that are leading Aiden
down the garden
I I don't give a [__] how drunk you are. Somebody
find me that progressive victory party where Chud is drunk off
his ass
talking about how blacks commit so much crime, okay? I don't
care how drunk you were, Chud. Come on, man. Like this guy has
no You're British to start with.
You're British to to from the offset, you're British. Like we
don't know how up people can get when they're drunk and say [__]
that they don't necessarily believe or think or whatever, right?
How do we try to pretend that being drunk here, being drunk enough
like wouldn't get you to think some [__] funny that
isn't really funny. I think there's And not only that, you lose
all context here. Nobody's thinking about the context here at
all. This is explicitly like 12 minutes I'm helping Aiden and
I don't want to. This loser, he's being such a dick through all
of this. But think about the context before and after this. This
is like a snapshot of where they are at the end of the conversation,
right? Like you start
you start slowly
Uh you said yesterday alcohol reveals who you are underneath.
Yes, like you become more amplified. And I said this revealed
the diseased mindset he had towards this Leo Kamboi guy, 100%.
But like the the excess of the jokes, I'm not going to get soy
about that cuz I it's again like a closed room setting, not private,
but like a reduced size of people, people who are like friends
with them. And this is like the worst part of the conversation.
Like you don't watch any of the build-up here at all, right?
And I think they start saying, well, I actually, you know, you
don't get to say you're drunk and and get, you know, absolved
of all the outcomes of your drunk actions. I don't think that's
true. I don't think you get absolved.
But I do think in terms of like your intent, you're talking [__]
you can forgive that.
I I do understand. I I don't even disagree with Chud. I just
think like acting like the comments are crazy in a vacuum, not
that bad. Acting like he might do some like he might go beyond
doxing even, that's true. Right? And that's really the heart
of the criticism. But I think it's way easier to look at the
comments themselves and say, oh, these are really bad. I might
be worried you might do these things or I might be worried you're
And he kind of tries to go back and forth. And I think there's
a lot of weight given by just going, oh my god, you want to ruin
this guy's life? And I think Chud does that a couple of times.
I just don't think it it doesn't help. It's not like a good argument.
It's not really anything. It's just sort of using the the weight
morally of being able to do that. Yes, I will make that point
eventually that yeah, he's basically green-lighting his own community
for this stuff, the people around him for this stuff, which is
insane, obviously,
right? I do think he's doing that. He's doing that through his
actions regardless of drunk or not. I just I didn't like the
way this got argued. >> And you're acting like a wallflower.
Where is your rage? Where is your anger in this call? Answer
now.
I had the rage, dude. This cuts off after I've just blown up
on Aiden. That's why me and Aiden on
That's That's the thing about this is this is basically like
recorded entirely
in the worst possible way. And I feel like Chud should be able
to realize
Now, and it's Chud's it's Chud's responsibility cuz I don't think
Aiden can make that argument. I Dickers can. I don't think Aiden
can even make that argument, right? Aiden's like so thoroughly
he just has to go and like kneel and accept his r- Like Aiden
And which Aiden tried to do. Aiden, you can tell he's like totally
not built for it, though.
I think it's Chud's responsibility to go, well, I don't know
what said before and after this.
You know what I'm saying? >> And a call together, by the
way. We are in the room together, dude. It's just an
tense silence where Aiden and I just exchanging glances at each
other You are too subservient to these Discord Why you're not
calling them out for doing this, bro? They're [__]
losers. >> I did. Dude, go back to the start of the first
call when Soul is saying British on Twitter. I'm saying he's
the worst person to be around. I'm saying he's the literally
the worst person to be around. Yeah, in the most passive fashion
and the weakest fashion. You're weakly batting at him as he's
leading your friend down the garden path of utter ruin and destruction,
bro, okay? This is like This is like someone is bringing someone
to a bank robbery, okay? That's going to end in their death and
you're like, oh, no, don't go. That's a bad idea. Right? You
should be raging out, crashing out of this, telling them what's
what. My god. Okay, so the I see it's [__] purged
now and so this is no longer
Um so I've got nothing to be able to confirm that I was, but
I was, okay? Soul has been angry since >> in this call
goes against that? You're acting like a
Dude, if you go and take a look at like if you can go and take
a look at like Himbleton's stream, Soul is still complaining
that I told him to last night. I'm not watching [__]
Himbleton's stream, dude. I barely watch your stream. You should
go watch Himbleton's stream. Dude, that's not going to work on
Chud at all. Dude, I felt I've never once felt like um sympathetic
to the Nicholas Yorio argument where he's like, I don't want
to know all of Desi Orbiter drama. I don't want to know any of
that. I've never felt sympathetic to that until Beckett started
telling me about the ACC drama and he's using all these proper
nouns and I'm just like, bro, you said like literally every proper
noun you just used, I have no idea who that is, what that is.
I just Every single one, I'm just like, you just said like 20
names. To be fair, he in a in a story where I'm asking about
one person brought up like 20 different names. And I'm like,
that's your an encyclopedia. What's ACC? Art community. Art commentary
community. Art commentary community. Some people who do like
art online and then they went like basically they'd be like commission
artists, I think. And they had like a community going for a long
time where those people would go and like comment on drama within
that niche community.
Yeah. Yep, that's the art commentary >> Well, I don't care
what Soul Skibidi says about it cuz he probably perceived it
in a certain way. I've listened to you talk
call and it's weak as based on the circumstances, bro. >> He's
talking about life ruination. Aiden is talking about life ruination
and you're going, well, as long as he's not doing that now, that's
okay.
Well, I think I think what Dickers is saying is I was just screaming
at him over to like stop the literal life ruination, like the
literal doxing, the literal things he was doing. And so now you
hear me like kind of calm down a little bit cuz I've gotten him
to stop doing the most behavior.
And I I'm Am I the only one who's like, yeah, I understand?
Who's like talked somebody down from something when they're drunk
and it's
they go to something less It's like, well, that's a step in the
right direction at least. Holy Hey, bro, this is catastrophic.
This is catastrophic. And then, Dickers, you get on a call with
him and you're literally getting the definition of doxing knowing
this happened. Explain that to me now. Go.
there's not much to explain there, okay? I'm drunk on this as
well. I didn't realize until this got [__] released
how [__] bad it was. That's it.
You're lying to me. You're lying to me. You knew but you didn't
want to talk about it cuz it wasn't public. Answer now. Yes or
no. Yes or no.
No. So you forgot So just to clarify, your claim is that you
forgot that Dickers was talking about murdering Leo Conroy's
wife.
Just to be And again, Chud brings up the and murdering.
I I actually think that's the least offensive thing here. The
thing that I was like, oh, the really weird comment Aiden made
through all of these videos that Chud really didn't bring up
the
Aiden started talking about how like, oh, I'm going to go like
make up um I'm going to go like invent comments like supporting
the ice shooter and then I'm going to get her fired from her
job with that. And then I'm going to like send her send her name
down Tifa. That was the weird thing where I'm like, oh, that
was like different. That's like something you could actually
do. Something that is like plausible online that like you probably
shouldn't be in addition to the literal doxxing in addition to
all the comments.
And that guy that asked to help, yeah, that guy's like, "Oh,
do you want her LinkedIn?" And I'm like, oh, that suddenly the
situation's like, "Jesus Christ, guys.
That's Okay. Now we're like Now that's bad. Nobody when he was
like talking about going to Leo Conroy's wife, nobody was like,
"Hey, do you need gas money?" That didn't happen, right? But
then they start talking about going to this guy's going to this
woman's job or like trying to get her fired from her job and
somebody's like, "Do you want Do you want her LinkedIn?" It's
like, "Get No. Huh? What the [__] are you guys doing
here?" is where that conversation actually gets bad for me. Um
which I didn't really catch the first time. I think I listened
to the second half of this trying to get something else set up
for the stream and didn't quite pay enough attention. I should
have paid a little more attention. It was a little crazy to me,
okay? If Is that correct? Uh I don't think she did. >> That's
your claim. You forgot You forgot about Yes. >> No, I didn't
forget that. You're talking about life ruination, not life ending.
So So you remembered him likely joking about murdering Leo Conroy's
wife, but you forgot about the point where Aiden
Chud Chud would never be friends or hang out with people who
joke about murdering
Never. Now I know he's going to say not after they were like
uh literally doxxing the person and I I get that. I don't think
the The doxxing is the problem and the continued obsession is
the problem. It shows that disease mindset where he is going
to go way over his own personal lines, right? But I think the
criticism to me just like stops there. And I think it's way easier
to argue that if you consistently say, "He's He tried to murder
them. He tried He tried to murder them. He tried to murder them.
He tried to murder his wife." I think it just gets easier to
make that, but that's just like emotional signaling that I don't
think like it it looks good. Everybody in the audience loves
it,
Everybody in the audience loves it. I get it. I do get it. But
it just I doesn't feel like quite correct to me. Unscathed, you
say? Oh, um I already said literally when I started the
So we do a little lying in the title just to get some some clicks.
That was just a little bit of lying, okay? We do a little lying.
was talking about wanting to do life ruination. I don't believe
you. I do not believe you.
doing grassroots campaigns to like say that she's supporting
the ice murder. Okay. And I did not remember that until this
talk came up.
complete lying wretch. I'm not talking about the specific [laughter]
grassroots campaigns to like say that she's supporting the ice
murder. Okay. And I did not remember that until this talk came
up. So Dickers even identifies the worst part of this. complete
lying wretch. I'm not talking about the specifics. I'm talking
about broadly. He was talking about doing life ruination. The
point is he was The other thing that I think Chud is missing
here that maybe this should be a bigger thing.
I'm guessing Aiden actually talks about Leo Conroy in private
a lot. I'm guessing that like this didn't seem out of bounds
or weird because I'm guessing Aiden is consistently talking about
this guy almost all the time.
You know what I'm saying?
So like I I think it's like no, it's like about normal for Aiden
and maybe you're the frog in boiling water that, you know, Yeah,
he's talking about Leo Conroy and his wife again. That That's
what he does. That's all he talks about.
Were you not in IC chat? No, I never joined IC chat. Never never.
Uh he talks about Leo and Goat Cato a lot in private. Wait. Also,
I saw a clip of Aiden admitting to having a crush on some random
e-girl
like a year and a half ago, 2 years ago from a Chud stream. It's
like uh Larynx
Who's that e-girl
in that situation?
Actually don't know. >> talking about doing life ruination.
You did remember that even if you didn't know the details. So
why don't you bring that up rather than litigating the meaning
of doxxing? The meaning of doxxing is irrelevant when Aiden is
on a call talking about life ruination. Yes or no? Uh yes. I
brought up Aiden said that night to him when he had a conversation
on call and every time it's him batting it away and saying that
he's drunk and saying that it's jokes.
Tell you what. Listen, okay? Watch and learn from the master,
okay? When Aiden hops on, watch my stream and I'll show you how
it's done cuz you This is You've totally This Nobody Nobody took
what I said seriously when I was saying that Aiden was trying
to do this and saying if he doesn't want his wife doxxed, he
should speak to me in the debate.
Did Perry get on this stream at some point? Bro, I fell asleep.
Oh, Perry got on this stream? Oh, there's actually going to be
good content at the end of this. Nobody took that seriously cuz
nobody can hear him
Okay, so that's another indication that my title's just a lie.
I didn't even watch the whole thing. saying it. I guess everyone
just thought, yeah, fair enough, he's drunk. He's drunk all the
time. Everybody's fine with it. Okay. Why are you Okay. Why are
you
litigating the detail of whether he was serious about life ruination,
okay, is way more critical to this than what the exact definition
of doxxing is, okay? The argument is simply that the intention
is that don't
I think the issue is, how do I put it? I Man, I I should have
watched a little more of this and thought about it before stream.
But I didn't.
The issue is like it is solved that Aiden is willing to engage
in tactics against Leo Conroy that he himself would obviously
denounce. He has given up his principles to go after this Leo
Conroy guy in a way that he can't at all defend. And he has tried
to to defend it multiple times, okay? Now that this has come
out, he feels like he can't. Now that Chud's against him, he
feels like he can't. But I think Aiden probably
has zero new information, right? The only new information is
that Chud Logic is against him. It's very weird seeing I I'll
be honest, I got some IC leaks that I can't share, okay? But
some people leaked IC chat to me and it's very obvious that a
ton of his like audience is downstream of Chud and that like
they just swayed their opinions entirely with Chud. It's like
very weird to watch, right?
To me, but it's
>> like it was already true that Aiden had been exposed
on this.
And I just think that these calls they they helped to cement
it, just not in a way that like I I don't think what he's saying
in these calls is actually like relevant in terms of the the
amplitude. It's like the the directionality is what gives you
the information you need to say, "Oh, he's in trouble. He made
really bad decisions here." And I think I do actually think that
perhaps when you add all this stuff together. I didn't think
so yesterday, but after hearing and arguing with some other people,
not Chud, by the way, not Chud. Oh, he said he would murder them.
Not that guy, okay? But with some other people, I'm like, ah,
I think maybe Aiden should stop covering Leo Conroy.
I do think Well, that's Ringle I said that's probably the biggest
indictment of his character. Of Aiden's character was that I
don't think any real new information has come out. I think basically
as it's become public, he's like obviously stood on business
when not enough of it is public, right? But then the public information
comes out and you do see that he's I believe kind of lied, kind
of like uh just just
As things are as things come out, he he continues to just like
update the story, which I don't like. It's not a good indication,
okay? Remember that he's talking about life ruination. Okay,
but you do remember him talking about murdering his wife, correct?
Uh yeah. Okay. So why on the call, rather than talk So Okay.
I don't believe the life ruination point, okay? But we'll put
that to one side. We'll put that to one side. In the call, you
were litigating doxxing, okay? Did you talk in the call about
him talking about murdering his wife? Yes or no?
Why Okay, so you remember
They did. But they said that and you thought it was more critical
to litigate the meaning of
So it's fair for the Discord calls to be leaked, right? Um I
think it was very unfair and nobody's going to defend it cuz
they're going to think they're defending Aiden on this.
Cuz Aiden is going to try to run in circles on this. I'll just
I'll just say yes, it's obviously true that the whole call should
be released. That you can't release just the end where this like
has come to a head and you've already talked this guy down from
the doxxing itself. You can't just release that part. You got
to release the whole thing, man. How you only going to release
12 minutes of this whole call?
You got to release the whole thing.
But I I do think it's fair to release this to say like Aiden
is lying. Aiden is lying about like how deranged she is about
the guy. doxxing rather than him talking about murdering Leo's
wife. Why?
Well, I think if you want to prove that it's malicious, you can
already point to the fact that Aiden said on that night that
he's talking about
Oh, I
No, I have no problem with this getting leaked. I just would
want the whole thing leaked. I think it's I think it's leaked
with the exact context needed to hang Aiden by somebody who's
looking for drama. Which by the way is why Aiden shouldn't be
talking about personal [__] with people who are in
his like icy chat. Like those people are people who have way
too much time to spend on Discord. They are looking for some
drama they can start and they will act like normal human beings
towards you. They will act like they care about you, but the
second they see that they can get something out of this from
release it from like leaking [__] They will leak
it instantly.
Um I've been over the past like I want to say like 3 weeks. For
for 2 years I've streamed, okay? For 2 full years I've streamed.
And I felt like my audience is pretty human, pretty normal for
like 20 months, 22 months.
And then there's just been
there's just been like a couple things where I'm like, oh,
my I have people I know from the audience that I'm like cool
with, that I wouldn't think this of, okay? That I do have like
personal conversations with. But they're very few and far between
and they're people who probably who watch my content when I like
would just do random politics streams with like 50 viewers. So,
little different. But um
everybody else will leak something on you the second they can
to hurt you in any way they can because that's all they're here
for. They're just here for like they're literally just here to
pretend that they're human until they can find some reason to
like be against you and then leak whatever you sent them. Anytime
Anytime you're honest with these people, you are hurting yourself.
It's uh it's it's weird, okay? Cuz the second they like see something
that makes them think, okay, I can actually go after this person,
they'll leak anything you've ever sent them. So, just for traders,
you got to be very careful about this [__] okay?
There are no allies, only future enemies and future enemies.
Well, it's just amongst the people who like this content, right?
You just you got to be really careful about that stuff.
And it's because they can easily flip to see you as like not
a person, right? Like while they see you as a person, they're
not like someone who would flip on their own family members like
this. They see this is like as like a game online and they can
immediately deperson you like at the drop of a hat. And so while
that's the case, while they can drop deperson you at the drop
of a hat,
um they they no longer consider you human. So, like I think a
lot of people are like, oh, they would they would, you know,
they're totally crazy, they have no real lives. I don't think
that's true. I think a lot of the people, people on Kiwi Farms
even, people on 4chan, people in all of these like most deranged
areas. I think they have fairly
human interactions in their lives by and large and this is like
a guilty pleasure for them, right? That's my opinion, but I think
it's the the ability to on the internet under anonymity just
totally deperson somebody and they they don't think you are worthy
of like human consideration anymore. That's that's what makes
this happen
Random rant, not really super important. Just basically saying
that Aiden should never trusted these people, but I think again
being drunk, I don't think Aiden would discuss this in an open
VC, I
I hope.
You know >> strong-arming Leo into a conversation, which
I did. What? Okay. Listen, shut the [__] up for 1
minute cuz you're and you know you are. Chat knows you are. You're
out of your depth, okay? [snorts] And listen. Very simple. Very
simple. What is going to prove malice more? The point that you
just made or the fact that Aiden was talking about and murdering
Leo's wife. What is the more compelling argument? >> Shut
up and listen. Everybody already >> listen. What is the
more compelling argument? Answer that and that alone. I'll be
honest and I I now don't remember what Dicker said. Shut the
[__] up for 1 malicious, you can already point to
the fact that Aiden doxing rather than him talking about and
murdering Leo's wife. Why? Explain.
Well, I think if you want to prove that it's malicious, you can
already point to the fact that Aiden said on that night that
he's talking about strong-arming Leo into a conversation, which
I did. What? Okay. Listen, shut the [__] up for 1
minute. Yeah, I actually I actually think Dicker's is right there.
I think Dicker's is right and Chud is like just soy signaling
at the murder like What's What's the better indication that Aiden
when significantly more sober talked about how he's going to
strong-arm Leo Conroy or when he's drunkenly singing
Run Leo's wife over with a boat. Say I'm the goat. He's like
doing his stupid rhymes while drunk. Like yeah, I think it's
actually his like
more sober mind saying that he wants to strong-arm this guy into
a conversation. He's willing to use his wife like the the threat
of his wife's stocks to do it. Yeah, I think that's a way better
indication actually.
But Chud is just yelling over Dicker's instead of actually listening.
>> cuz you're and you know you are. Chat knows you are.
You're out of your depth.
Who gives a [__] about what Chud thinks? >> listen.
Very simple. Very simple. What is going to prove malice more?
The point that you just made or I don't even think Chud's thinking
about it. I think Chud is like
Chud being angry is the best content. It's like pretty good content,
I I can now go listen to this like after the fact and point out
that like I think
like obviously here. >> or the fact that Aiden was talking
about and murdering Leo's wife. What is the more compelling >> Dude,
everybody Shut Which one Which one of those things is he seriously
engaging in now? Which one of those things is actually like the
Which one of those things is like again of sober mind? It's like
obvious it's the first one. >> and listen. Everybody already
knows. Shut up and listen. What is the more compelling argument?
Answer that and that alone. It's what Dicker said. But here's
the thing now. Chud has made no argument. He has just soy signaled.
He's turned this into um you you basically have to attack me
personally to make a response. I've made no argument. So, now
you just have to call me a soy instead of anything else if you
want to make the argument back. That's what he's turned it into.
And I don't think I don't think Dicker's is going to do that.
The fact that he's got a motivation, the first one, okay? The
fact that he's got a motivation
to be able to like exert some kind of malice on Leo Conroy is
more pertinent. Is more [clears throat] persuasive. Is more I
don't know, important than the fact that he's like drunk spouting
about I'm going to kill Leo.
Here's how Okay. Okay. Here's how you make the argument, right?
If he's literally getting the meaning of
the meaning of doxing is irrelevant. There's a call of you talking
about Uh I'm I'm not I'm literally quoting what Chud would say.
Or sorry, what Dicker's would say cuz they're British. No malice
there. Not using it as a slur against anybody. Literally just
saying it as a >> and murdering Leo Conroy's wife.
That's it. That's all you need to say. That's it. Not this Oh,
but you've got this thing where you're trying to debate him.
The first thing is the compelling argument that is incredibly
convincing. And obviously you're claiming you didn't know, which
is re But what makes it even more compelling is you back it up
by him talking about life urination with specificity
having access to her information and having posted it. That's
it. That's the argument. Simple.
Dicker's just made that argument, the last part. He he literally
just made that argument.
Cool. End of conversation.
Um and I Listen, it's possible that I'm just annoyed because
Chud did this to
>> That sounds bad. Sorry. I had some reward redemptions
there. He He did this to me where like I think he wasn't listening
to me and then he's just like yelling. So, maybe I'm just, you
know, bitter about that. That he just didn't listen to my points
and then yelled. He's like arguing with somebody that doesn't
exist,
But I don't think so. I think like if you were able to have a
calm conversation about it, I think what Dicker just said is
fine. It is funny watching Dicker get yelled at though. >> Any
questions? I
um no. Okay. >> Have a good moment. Thank you. Bye-bye.
Yeah. Uh like just to be clear there, um there's there's the
example There's the exact example here that we need of
Dicker's literally just has to say you're being a soy loser right
now. Like you're not making an argument. He basically has to
attack Chud personally. There's no ar- no argument that could
be made. Chud didn't listen to him.
but hey, maybe that's what Chud wants. Maybe he just wants to
have people come on and go, well, I guess I can't really argue
against this guy cuz he said cuz he said he said it. He said
he won. Well, far be it from me to argue. I get that it's funny
content though. He's
Oh, man. Yeah, Dicker's makes a joke after that about C Zig.
Any thoughts?
Any thoughts, guy? Sadly, you're right. Like you'd have to have
the Mr. Girl meta conversation there about how like badly those
arguments how bad those arguments were. What is your problem?
I'm cursed with knowledge. That's the problem. I'm cursed with
knowledge, dude. I'm cursed with knowledge.
That's the problem, guys. >> I've had two coffees today.
I've had two coffees today. I just don't have time for it, dude.
I don't have time. I don't have time to debate the specifics
of it. I know that I'm right. If people accept that I'm right,
it's a lot easier. It's a lot easier and then we just we can
save a lot of time, okay?
The sad thing is is there is an element here that I was saying
I wanted Chud to like to discuss this with people explicitly
because I do think 100%
that some of this it like starts getting discussed and like you're
intellectualizing every single conversation and entertaining
totally arguments that shouldn't be entertained. But I do think
Dicker's argument was one that could be like you got to be accurate,
right?
You got to be accurate the whole time. Oh, I also think I might
have gotten him to go off on Dicker's pretty hard.
Can I find my comment here? It's like up a little bit.
What did I say? I said something in here in his chat about how
like Oh boy, he's he's already getting ripped by Dicker's. Not
looking good for that Aiden
And I feel like you went harder. I don't Anyway, let's go to
the second Dickers convo. We'll calmly about this. >> Yeah,
yeah. It's okay. I was I was being real quick, real quick.
>> Um look, okay. If you don't mind if I just briefly explain
what you were saying in the DMs, right? It's not You're cool
with that, yeah? We'll see. Oh, sure. Yeah. Cuz what you were
basically saying is >> it more calmly. >> you didn't
bring didn't bring it up is because you worried it would make
you look soy or dramatic. And I don't think that's true >> cuz
you didn't tell Perry and those lot about how bad it was, did
you? Um
By the way,
I think Dickers did tell Perry and the other people that Aiden
was joking was talking about Leo's wife. I do think so. He just
not all of it. I do think he was talking The one thing Chud wants
to get back here is like you you hid this from the other people
on the trip cuz you didn't want him to get in trouble cuz you're
his friend. And I think that's respectable. And it's like I don't
think I think he told them with the ri- We're talking about the
uh the stream the stream conversation, is that right? What I'm
talking about is after so you know, bear in mind the chronology
in my head is not 100% but my understanding of it is you have
the call in IC where Aiden is doxing and going crazy talking
life for a nation, right? After that you saw Perry and Queenan
and whatnot again. After that, right? Uh well, what happens in
between those is that me and Aiden have a call later that night
where Aiden apologizes the first time and says that he was dumb
for it. No, no.
When he called you and spoke to you, you're saying he apologized
for it. My understanding is he said he took he said he was willing
to take like a minor L for it or something similar. Is that not
what happened?
well, not originally. So, Aiden calls me up and A minor L. We
made mistakes. I'll take a minor L on doxing as well. >> Mistakes
on both sides. I'll take I'll take a minor L on that. No, I press
him and then he says that he wants to take a
Oh, yeah. Spacial sound. You know, like you're on this call,
you know, you don't want to and and you know, you're saying about
how you can say about being seen perceived as soy which I I get
that's like, you know, a thing. People I get feeling concerned
about that. But like No, no, no. To be to clarify that as well,
just real quick. I'm not saying that I don't want people to think
of me as soy. I mean, that's going to happen regardless, right?
That's already the that's already a thing. I'm talking about
in the conversation.
Cuz I Okay, I uh I don't care about the rest of this. Aiden's
getting in. We've got Aiden. We've got Aiden joining the call.
Okay, here it comes.
Here's the Aiden Chud call. Here it comes. Right now. >> Sadly,
you're Aiden. Hello. Hello.
Hello. Hello. How you doing, mate?
I'm good. I've been I've been actually been watching the stream
but uh I can probably Not starting off strong on the lying or
telling the truth front, okay? Not starting off powerfully.
That's what Not great. Uh I actually haven't even been watching
the stream.
Who asked? Literally, who asked?
>> Hello. Hello. How you doing, mate?
I'm good. I've been I've been actually been watching the stream
but uh
How you doing? I'm good. I haven't been actually watching the
stream. Who Who
Who asked? Who asked about that? >> probably assume we've
gone over so far.
Yeah, we can get to that. Um first of all, can we just uh I guess
let's clarify some details, shall we?
Okay. I mean, really it's where to begin to be honest. Um we
could start with the biggest stuff or the smallest stuff.
I think we'll start with the biggest stuff and just get straight
into it, okay? So, first of all, your story has changed on this
repeatedly. So, what is
the current story
that you are telling about this claim of you doxing or spreading
the docs of Leo Combo's wife?
okay. I guess the story has always been
the story has always been I I essentially
uh I did something like really dumb when I was like drunk at
Dickers and I like impulsively
um
like I impulsively
uh had uh
Uh this is like a wild thing to say. I don't think I I think
that's crazy. I don't know. Why are you saying Slime, you always
come here and you say like the most ri-
Can you just be like chill? Have you ever come here and just
been like chill for 2 seconds?
Literally, every single person we ever cover on stream or even
times where I don't cover them, you'll just bring up how somebody's
like a ri-
Like that's probably just mental illness, okay? It's not as bad.
[sighs] I'm telling you, it's probably if every single person
in your life is a it's probably just mental illness. Uh had spread
uh this person's uh face and their name um and I had uh pretended
like I I pretended like I knew where they worked. Um my recollection
is that didn't know where they worked. Apparently, I've read
through their papers I'm I'm sorry, mate. This is [__]
outrageous, dude. You're already trying to put on my boots and
tell me it's raining, okay? Let's get very [__]
Um is he saying it was an accident? I think he was saying it
was a mistake.
I don't think that's the same as saying it was an accident.
Like it was wrong to do. He shouldn't have done it. It was a
mistake.
I I don't think that's Maybe I'm misinterpreting.
I I don't get it would be for him to say it was like something
I didn't intend.
No, he obviously had the intention. That would be insane for
him to say, "Oh, I didn't intend to do that." >> [__]
clear here, okay? You started off after you posted it when you
were drunk in the Discord, your first story is that the docs
was fake. That was your first story, wasn't it? But where did
I say I I'm sorry, but I just like I legitimately never W- Where
did I say that? Okay. The thing is, you This is the narrative.
You started off saying it was fake. This is broad, okay? Now,
if you want the specifics and the detail, we
Um the I think the thing he said here was that he didn't like
he made up the the occupation or the place of work or
I think that's I still don't know the the whole truth of this
but I think what he was arguing on Dickers was he made up the
place of work. The rest of it is all docs information. He should
have just apologized, right? But what he did instead was try
to quibble over whether or not the occupation stuff was real.
When realistically, you don't need that you don't need any of
that information to say he docs this woman. We can get into that
and we can narrow it down, okay? But this But I've always said
that's real, man.
Let's just get the details clear because I'm not going to get
into the weeds with you on little piddly details of this, okay?
When the broad narrative is largely correct. The piddly details
>> Yeah, it is. It is. Let me lay it out. Let me lay it
out and you can tell me what I disagree with, okay? Sure, go
ahead. You either claimed or at least put doubt on the idea that
the docs that you had shared was real. The story then changed
to, "Well, it is real but it's not really doxing because it was
already publicly available." Then you changed the story to, "Oh,
it was a docs actually but doxing is morally neutral and I'm
utilitarian. So, I think it was okay to do it." Okay. I mean,
I Here's my issue right now. Like I'd love to address all that
but it's going to look like I'm getting all hyper fixated on
the details. Several of that those things were were Okay, what
Tell me tell me one thing that you want to say that substantively
changes what I've claimed.
Yeah, sure. I've never claimed that her information was fake.
I've never The only Even even if it's not exactly true that you
even if it's not exactly true, okay? That you that you said her
information was fake. That doesn't substantively change it because
the
This is basically like the kind of stuff that um yeah, this is
basically the kind of stuff that Aiden gets in trouble for. Um
not what he's doing right now but what Chud's describing is broadly,
I'm mad at you because you docs this woman she's wife. And he
goes, "Well, originally he was arguing it wasn't a docs because
some of the information was publicly available." And then I think
what happened was is it turns into, "Well, the the occupation
or something where she worked wasn't publicly available but
but so that I think that's where the the the faking part gets
to is like he's like, "Well, all of it was publicly available
and then this other thing was I it was fake." Right? So, he's
saying because publicly available plus fake, I don't docs.
And it's like, "Well, one, he kind of made up the first part
where it was all He fudged the He fudged all of it, right? So,
he's going to make claims that well, like possibly technically
true, lead people totally away from the truth, right? Like there
is some technical way you could maybe massage this that Aiden
possibly hasn't done anything. But he did grab a bunch of this
person's information. He did have it from a bunch of places and
he posted it in a place that's she's likely to get harassment
from. He's built a community over the past couple months that
would be likely to be very angry at these people and could possibly
do something with that information, right?
That's why it's bad. And that core reason of why it's bad, how
it was bad, doesn't change no matter how he gets into any detail.
And what it seems like is he dives into these details because
he knows he can argue them forever and the conclusion never resolves.
Basically, you have these like ever like ever extending trees
of dialogue where you never get back to the top and say that
conclusively, Aiden is bad for doxing this woman. And it's very
frustrating when probably everybody can understand that Aiden
is bad for doxing this woman.
And so, Chud lays out a bunch of those things and that
it's hard to know exactly where to draw the line. There's somewhere
you can draw the line here where Chud should be more accurate
than he's being, but also Aiden should be less fighty than he's
being, but nobody wants sorry Aiden doesn't want to like get
to the truth as much as everyone else and I think Chud has decided
what the truth is and he doesn't care about being a little sloppy
on the way to getting Aiden to >> it is. You have changed
your story about this and lied about this.
I've never lied about this. I won't admit to that at all. My
story did not My story did not substantially change um and I
You tried to claim that the picture that you posted was a random
woman that you found online. Yes or no?
I've never I have never said that's not true like at all. And
that's a major detail by the way. That's not like small pedantic
I challenge you and anyone else to find where I said that. Okay.
Okay. In any case regardless of the Well the Okay. How about
the fact that you made up the place where she worked?
So you claim that you made up the place where she worked. Yeah,
I don't know where she works.
Okay. But the work
Um hold on. Wait wait wait wait wait.
What are you saying Maximus? What are you saying? Sorry I I'm
literally getting uh
I got pinged by somebody
while I'm streaming about Discord stuff. And I as you all know
that's uh it's a big no-no okay? Pinging me about Discord [__]
while I'm streaming.
Not good. Not good. So I Now I have to go back and see what this
was I have to real quick. us Well the Well the Okay. How about
the fact that you made up the place where she worked?
[__] That's a backfire. >> never said that's
not true like at all. I tried to apologize for what I did. You
tried to claim that the picture that you posted was a random
woman that you found online. Yes or no? I've never I have never
said that's not true like at all. And that's a major detail by
the way. That's not like small pedantic I challenge you and anyone
else to find where I said that.
Maximus you think he claim I don't recall this as in a single
place that he said it was just some random woman that
unless it was a clear joke like with clear very clear like intonation
to say it was a joke. I don't think that happened. I'm almost
positive that didn't happen that he said the picture was a totally
random woman he had no idea. Unless Did that happen also? Okay.
I don't I don't recall it but In any case regardless of the Well
the Okay. How about the fact that you made up the place where
she worked? Yeah?
So you claim that you made up the place where she worked. Yeah,
I don't know where she works.
Okay. But the workplace was real wasn't
No. I don't I don't know I still don't know where she works.
That's a lie. You're lying. I I I would I mean I just like I'd
love to say >> so happened Man I have a theory about
I have a theory about this okay?
I don't know I don't know if I can abstract it enough to say
what I think
Hypothetically hypothetically okay? He got it on on Kiwi Farms
or something. Oh but I know Dickers accused him of finding it
on Kiwi Farms and that's
But I do think there's like some idea for how he thinks he did
this. I'm trying to see if I can cuz like the argument he's trying
to make is like funny. Dude I don't know I don't know if you
can talk about it if it's like fair game. Oh hold on I'll try
to see. Okay. Let's say that you knew
that Leo Conboy
lived in
The Pentagon is in DC right? I assume it is but it could also
be in like Virginia or something. I think it's in DC though.
Let's say that
Leo Conboy's wife you knew that she worked in like security and
they lived vaguely around DC.
And you said she works at the Pentagon as like a meme as a joke
cuz you knew she worked vaguely in like national security some
field related and then you found out that she actually worked
at the Pentagon.
I think that's like a kind of argument Aiden is trying to make.
Arlington County Virginia. Okay so it is outside of DC. So they
live in Virginia or somewhere. Yeah Arlington that makes sense.
Okay. Very close anyway. I'm just I'm just laughing that I think
that's like the argument he's trying to make. I don't think I
believe it. I think he does know and he just knows that that
would be way over the line like in a way that's totally unforgivable.
Like or it it feels unforgivable under his own principles.
So I I think he's lying but I don't know but I think it's something
like that okay? Where basically he knows kind of where they live.
He knows kind of something about her field and he would just
pick like the most obvious example to say oh she works here or
something.
And then she does actually work there and it's like well I think
I think that's what he's trying to do. Okay? happened to guess
the place that she worked. You just so happened I mean am I allowed
to [laughter] say the place that the place that I had made up
was literally I literally Okay. It's going to be the pro
if that information was out online somewhere that you could reasonably
expect Aiden to look as somebody who A-logs Leo Lio Conboy I
wouldn't believe him that he just didn't know it.
Right? I'm sorry.
I think you I think you can't believe that and that's unfortunate
that you had When you take everything in totality it absurd to
believe that. I'm just I'm going to try to entertain these things
for Aiden as as best I can cuz I do think he's he's not going
to get any of that. If I had an argument with him I would probably
be cutting him off in a similar way to Chud to The problem is
I can't reiterate to you but like if people heard what I had
said yeah that it's like totally plausible that that was made
up because of Yeah Dickers did say that he saw him browsing KF
Leo Conboy's KF page. He did say that. I'm just saying that I'm
trying to give what his argument is which it feels a little absurd.
And realistically it's like that was going to be a risk right?
There there is I don't expect a lot of people to expect it but
when you guess the most obvious answer you when you apply Occam's
razor in a way that could affect somebody's life and then you
happen to be correct with that with that most likely guess there's
probably something bad about >> and I concede that the
name was real and the face was real. I if if the workplace was
real I have no problem conceding to that cuz it would make me
look just as bad as I already look cuz I did do something wrong.
No no it would make you look way worse. Right? So no I did like
I did make that one up. We can we can all understand that right?
That like you've now there's like the name and face. Somebody
could use that to find further information to to like inflict
harm on somebody to harass them in real life right? But if you
post the address if you post like a workplace with an address
that is far worse actually. That makes it far worse obviously
because now somebody doesn't even have to go look up that those
additional details right? It's weird how you're squirming like
this. >> But but like if you disagree I I don't know what
to say. Like
Because my understanding of it then is and listen obviously I'll
admit I don't know the intricacies of some of this stuff okay?
And that's why I want to talk about the broad details.
But I will get into some of the intricacies here okay? So you
made a claim about the kind of Okay. So it's exactly what I said.
Maximus yep exactly what I've been saying the whole time is yeah.
So you said you got mad when Chud said you said this was a fake
picture and Aiden said no that's a conclusive lie and then Chud
said okay you said the work details were fake and then Aiden
said yes. the job that she did and it just so happened that the
job she actually did was more or less the same as what you claimed.
>> No I only know I only know the general occupation she
does cuz Lio says that's Lio said Can I like can I say what Lio
says? Like I mean I could DM it to you like I could DM it to
you.
Like it it actually it makes like I mean it
I would say that even if you could find one example of Lio himself
putting some of this information out I'm guessing that finding
that would have happened
uh in post-production of this whole scandal okay? That you could
you could like find it and say well actually technically under
some people's definition like Beckett well technically he said
it himself once so actually I really don't think it's I really
don't think it's the same. Bro shut up. That's like this is like
the kind of stuff that I do think gets him in trouble that it
is frustrating. There's nothing worse when it's somebody who's
like hateable
and they're trying to block you from like hating them. They're
like trying to say they're like doing the the these little like
nitpicking to like There's everybody hates you more on the internet.
Yeah oh sorry I know I know he's lying weed. I I already explained
what I think he's trying to go with for an explanation.
You just maybe weren't here. I've already explained what I think
he's trying to go with. Um you might have to roll it back. But
yes I do believe he's lying.
Like if the if the information is out there and then Dickers
is going to say actually you looked at the Kiwi Farms page and
then you've got a whole community that's built on Lio Conboy
hatred. Right? You've got a whole bunch of these people in your
community that have done like some fairly I I I've heard bad
things. Right? Um it's very interesting
how this all lines up by the way with a lot of allegations made
against my
Um I think some people who are really dumb might might look at
this and go like look you're you're saying it's about his community.
It's not. It's about Aiden's little old doxing of
In a in a pseudo public VC or sorry pseudo public channel.
That led to all of this right? The the bad event we have proof
of the bad thing before any of the arguments about community
coming in. >> It makes total sense. Um but I don't even
know like is it like I don't even care like at this point like
if you just say I did it's not even You're right that isn't like
a major point cuz you still have the name and the face. I'm being
honest I have no reason to lie about that when I'm already conceding
to the two other things. So okay. Well then in that case why
are you bringing up is a standard detail that changes anything?
I'm willing to grow up and try to be but you are trying to drag
me into the week. No, no, no. No, no, no. I changed it. I said,
"What have I said that substantively changes the narrative?"
And you're now admitting it doesn't really change it anyway.
>> claim that I lied is a pretty big is a pretty big detail.
I haven't lied. I haven't lied about anything. I did I did spread
some
Um it's Aiden in the specific VC full of people hyping him to
doxx that's the issue for sure.
Yeah, Soul Skim is pretty bad there. Like again,
I'm willing to because I understand like social dynamics. I'm
I'm willing to say that like I understand that happens with Soul
like like he they're drunk and they're going like doing this
thing. And Dickers was good setting them straight. The thing
that seems totally to me is
he says like I'm going to make up comments about this woman like
supporting the ice shooter to get her fired from her job. And
then somebody cuts in and goes, "Wait, do you want her
>> It's like, "Okay, there There's a big problem There's
a big problem here. Holy Holy Holy like this. Not jokes anymore."
Somebody's like, "You're starting to build a bear towards like
actually doing shitty like terrible [__] here, right?
Aiden's saying he's not liar here. Can you succinctly say all
the lies that you know you can roughly back up the lies you could
roughly back up from what they are? Um he says he's not familiar
with the Willy Mac drama. I do believe he did commentary in the
Willy Mac drama. I believe he watched the Willy Mac video. I
do believe he's aware pretty pretty intimately to like at least
enough to make all of the the commentary he needs to of how and
why like how and under what circumstances Willy Mac's wife was
doxxed and how it's similar to this. Like you have all the pieces
you need based on him watching the video, the Willy Mac video,
right? I think he he had commentary there, so I think that is
a blatant lie. Um it seems like the lie about Kiwi Farms, right?
He did He never went to the Kiwi Farms page. The lie about not
posting her her occupation, right? He has like little tenuous
ways he can argue around all of these things. Proving a lie 100%
is really difficult, right? Requires proving intent. But every
one of the comments he makes that's untruthful that's that's
we find out is untruthful after the fact, they all skew in his
direction. And that's what I always say about this, right? When
every single little little um fib you do skews in your direction
when you're like in a drama you feel like you're fighting for
your life, I'm going to call that lying. You are lying, okay?
He literally says, "I don't know where she works." So again,
um I'll give you guys the the metaphor here so you can understand
it, okay? I think what what essentially happens is Aiden goes
he does something akin to the we we know these people live in
Leo has talked about his wife works for the government in security
or something. And Aiden starts joking about how she works at
the Pentagon.
This is what his argument is. And then he finds out that she
actually worked at the Pentagon. Like she She works for the government.
She's in like, you know, national security or something. She
works for like the military government something like this. And
Aiden goes, "She works at the And then it turned out she did
work at the Pentagon. That's the argument he's trying to make.
I think you'd have to be
you'd have to be insane to agree with that to think that's true.
That wasn't what he claimed. It is what he claimed,
I You're You're trying to argue this. Hop in the VC. Just hop
in the VC cuz we'll I just hop in the VC. No, no, hop in the
VC.
Hop in the VC cuz we'll just talk it out. I could be I could
be wrong, but I I understand how he went through this, right?
What he did, I understand what he said. My next point what he
said, I won't say it. Oh, go ahead and send it to me then cuz
I actually don't know what he said precisely like in terms of
the doxxing.
Wait, I think I do, but it's [__] gay that you're
going to Damn me. I'm so annoyed, but it's fine. Someone is not
not as wrong. I would admit whether or not you've lied about
this pales in comparison into some of the other things that you've
done, okay? I agree and I'll I'll I'll admit to all those things.
So I believe that you did lie in regards to the occupation, but
it's irrelevant because whether you saying you didn't lie, it's
irrelevant to the broader issue here, okay? In that you changed
your story repeatedly on this. Why did you change your story
a few times in regards to the doxxing? Why did you start saying
it was some of it was fake and then why did you change it to
it is doxxing and it's justified? Explain that. So my my position
changed. The story didn't. Um I my opinion of what I did, what
it constituted as, it did change. And I was hyper defensive when
I shouldn't have been.
So that like my own opinion and retelling of like what you would
Aiden Maximus not sleeping for Aiden. I What Maximus just said
to me is precisely in line with everything I've said on the stream,
so I'm very confused. I don't know where the missing >> classify
what I did as, that did change. The details of the story though.
Okay. So you admit now that you did doxx her by standards that
you would have applied
And on top of that as well, it's involved in >> no. But
by my standards, no. But I understand But I understand I spread
a doxx which is the same [__] And like Yeah, you
spread a doxx and that's something that you would have criticized
say a year ago. Yes or no?
Um yeah, I would have. That's why I'm admitting that it's wrong.
Sure. But that's my point. And my point with all of this is you've
turned into an ACC
Wait, did he say I never made up any workplace? I thought he
said I I did make up the workplace details.
I Maybe he said in this com But I he did make up the And I think
we end up reconfirming he says in here that yeah, I did. I didn't
know where she worked, so I like I couldn't I couldn't say where
she worked cuz I didn't That's what I'm trying to get at here.
That's what he's been arguing. He admitted to it in this combo.
Sorry, keep going. My bad.
No, go on. I don't know. I was saying like if you if you think
I'm going to deny that I I made like a pretty big mistake,
um you're not you're not going to get that. Um even though even
though I've been incredibly defensive and I'm willing to accept
accountability on it. Um imagine like I you don't care Hey, you're
talking about accountability, bro. You're bro, you're radioactive.
It's over, man. You are Flamenco 2.0. You are Flamenco
I don't I don't know. I mean I didn't run for what? Like Now,
I will say the Flamenco 2.0 thing, it is very similar. So Flamenco
apparently had a drama where he threatened to call Zander Hall's
like mom or something, okay?
And it is very similar to this. It is very similar, but I do
believe Flamenco had like 10 more very embarrassing dramas that
contributed to his downfall like after the fact, right? Um Why
does he just make it a global emote, Pilkington? And then you
could use it in other places. Yes, you are wrong. It's a one-off
mistake. I think it's recoverable. I'll explain it to you. No,
it's not recoverable, dude. It's over. Anyone that has engaged
in the behavior that you've engaged in Um this is also totally
wrong from Chud. This is like totally wrong. This is way over
the top. Um even if
I don't think this is really blocking from from growing. I don't
I Oh, yeah. No, Pilkington. I I understand the meme. I'm saying
that if he makes it a global emote, you could use it in other
channels. Like I use my my emotes in his channel all the time.
Cuz most of my emotes are global. Yeah, he could totally survive
this. This could be like nothing. This could be like a drunken
mistake that he just totally admits like he did and he [__]
up and he shouldn't do it ever again.
literally the literally the stupid performative celebrity playbook
is what you should do here. It's like, "I made a mistake. I got
drunk. I'm going to go I'm going to make sure I don't drunk anymore.
I'm going to like fix this. Uh I apologize to this guy." You
could just do that and then you just move on with the the coverage.
But man, Boom Flam was my first commentary streamer. Uh-oh.
Yeah, Steven Dueling just asked people for the CliffNotes version.
I've done a lot of follow-ups.
Can't just constantly re-litigate it all the time. Oh, uh-oh.
Stinkus Biggleton, who's apparently gifted subs here even though
I don't recognize the name. That's like a name change or something.
I don't even know. Says, "Aiden has been posting the wife's doxx
in IC for over a month."
No shot.
Uh does that That might make things a lot worse. That might make
things a lot worse for his community.
Um that might get more into like If that's true, I do think that
you probably have to totally stop covering Leo Convoy. If that
were true. If If If that were true. That would be rough because
then it is not a drunken mistake, then it is actually quite bad.
Now, that is just one random chatter who's not said anything
in this in this stream for like a year first started following
like a year and a half
So I don't know. I don't know if we can trust this one random
chatter. That would be really bad if he's been posting elements
of this doxx in that in IC chat for months.
Now, hold on. Stinkus Biggleton, do you have any more information?
Do you have anything more to this allegation? How
What What elements of PII was he posting? Don't post the actual
elements here. Just say like name name, workplace, whatever the
picture. You You can tell me what he was actually posting that
was going on in there for a long time and maybe maybe I'd be
interested. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. >> over. You
might be able to garner 10 viewers on a stream obsessing about
Leo Convoy for the rest of your days. A couple of ACC shits watching
you, but and it's over. That is it, dude. There's no other way
Sorry, I feel that way.
It's not about feeling that way, dude. It's about
That response right there, it's like Aiden Aiden can never actually
be humble. Aiden can fake being humble for like 30 seconds. He
can never be humbled, right? Like that comment right there, even
though it is not material to the argument, like I No, no, no,
no, no. I'm not on Twitch. I'm not on Twitch. It's fine. Uh we're
currently banned from Twitch. All right. But that that comment
right there is just the entire problem with Aiden. It's like
the entire problem.
It's a microcosm. A perfect microcosm. That it's like this is
the moment where you should be humble, you should be taking your
like your licks on this.
By the way, part of taking your licks on this is not going and
trying to like have these online conversations. There's some
weird brain rot that like oh you you have to go and defend with
everybody who's criticized you.
Right? Like if you did something wrong and you just say I'm sorry,
I did this, you make one public post and then you move on. Constantly
re-litigating it is content that is a part of like the lolcow
spiral. You do like one stream, you do like one thing and then
you say okay, I'm not re-litigating this again. If you can't
deal with the hate after that, you can maybe make one artifact,
okay? One artifact that is a solid piece of of information, an
article, a video that says here's my apology, here's like how
the situation went, here's what I'm willing to admit to, here's
how I feel about it, here's why it's not going to happen again.
You post that and then you just give that to people instead of
making the arguments again, right? But constantly giving it oxygen,
constantly re-litigating it will mean people constantly look
into it and you might have somebody like that guy who came in
here with one message and no other content, no other no other
anything where he's like oh Aiden has like said this, he's he's
posted a lot of this stuff multiple times. It's like oh, that
would be really bad. Obviously that would be really really really
bad. At some point you need to ignore the haters or you slip
into lolcow mode. Exactly.
But that's how it is. You can think I'm wrong about this, but
we'll look to the future and we'll see what happens. And I promise
you, okay? This stream is done, bro.
Now to me, it doesn't make a difference, right? I don't care
one way or another what happens with you for you, bro. But the
fact that you were trying to deny, okay? When you've already
been through weeks and weeks of obsessing about Leo Conroy, that
this is somehow going to, you know, not have an impact. Like
you're radioactive, dude.
Let's get onto that. So the doxing,
if by radioactive Chud means people won't stand with you not
because you did something morally wrong, but because standing
with you, you've basically painted a target on all of your friends
and family members' backs,
then that would be a good use of radioactive. I don't know what
he means by radioactive here if people just like say this is
morally wrong so they won't hang out with you. I think um there's
an element to that.
Like if this was just all done in like a rage out moment that
that he made really bad decisions while he was drunk and totally
rattled from some personal [__] that was getting
leaked about him. If that were the case,
I could forgive it, right? I know a lot of people don't like
that principle of like oh I I basically don't judge people by
their absolute worst moments.
I know people don't like that. People hate that about me, okay?
But I do think it's important.
You think it's good? Ethan Clark, thank you very much. Thank
you for the update, Kathy. I will look into that, okay?
But I I don't believe you judge somebody from how they act at
their absolute worst. I think you find some median and you you
need more than one piece of that bad conduct, right? Just one
piece of that bad conduct, it's not like enough. So we'll see
if that if that rumor that he has been posting this PII for like
months, if that's true,
cuz he definitely he definitely threatened Leo Conroy's wife
before this like quite badly. Let's just clarify. You admit that
you doxxed or
Uh point and laugh at this guy. Point and laugh at this guy.
Point and laugh at this guy. Point and laugh at this guy. Point
and laugh at this guy. Spread the doxx at the very least and
you agree that that's wrong based on your own standards. Yeah,
yeah, I spread the doxx, that was wrong.
Now let's move on to the other points of your behavior here,
okay? Because there's some pretty egregious flamenco tier behavior
here, okay? And I just use that to make it simple for everyone
you obviously shared the doxx info. Alongside that, you responded
to Leo Conroy. I believe this was before you shared the doxx,
but you can clarify if you wish, joking about phoning his wife
in order to pressure him to debate.
Explain that to me. Yeah, that was like a I totally stand like
I stand by the jokes, absolutely. >> Okay. Okay. So you're
saying it's a joke, right? But you you said it was a
Hey guys, stand by the jokes is might be like the most ambiguous
way of saying that. And I agree. No, no, no. Well, it could be
a little bit I said it I did say it was a joke and I said jokingly
when I tweeted out about it, right? Okay, I was
just using what you just said. Okay. Because I'm willing to grant
that it's a joke in and of itself, okay? But do you think, right?
Knowing that you've got the doxx information of the wife, okay?
And you're spreading it, do you think to me that would increase
or decrease the chances that you're joking? No, okay. Sorry.
Just to clarify, what you're asking me is
I'm sorry. I Can you say it one more time? It's my bad. So what
I'm trying to So Aiden has been having this problem is a at a
meta level of problem Aiden's been developing is he often jokes
in the exact direction he believes, right?
So like he does he does some jokes. This is it's just it's like
all of the Hellbent stuff, like how he would joke about how Hellbent
was evil and then he actually was like unable to control his
emotions with regards to Hellbent. There is like some argument
that he's doing these joking things, but he's joking at something
he truly like really thinks. It's not a joke in the sense and
and it's blending. And
and Perry brought it up as a problem and I do think it is a problem
for him, right? Where he is starting to like he's joking all
in a direction he really believes, right? So you can say it's
a joke and maybe the like level is a joke, but it's like you
really do hate these people. You really do. It's like you're
not joking about hating them. You're not joking about willing
to do really up [__] to get them to do what you want.
You're joking about like literal like you you're not literally
going to but you will go over the line by a lot.
You've shown that. So I I think there's like some valid criticism
here. I hope Chud lands it >> Clarify cuz you're saying
it's a joke, okay? So I'm looking at the tweet in and of itself
of you responding to Leo Conroy talking about phoning his wife.
On the face of it, I'd say that's an edgy joke, okay?
I have then found out that you have got her doxx information
and are spreading it in your Discord. Do you think in my head
that would increase or decrease the chances that you're joking?
It would probably increase it. Um but assuming I Sorry, no, no.
As in, you No. So what you're saying is knowing the doxx information
in my head Decrease, decrease, decrease. You think I'm being
serious? No, no, sorry. My bad. You think I'm being serious?
I'd still probably think it was an edgy joke,
But you would agree that that becomes less likely in a reasonable
person's head because then you know, well, they've got the doxx
information, right? >> Yes, yeah, yes, yeah. Okay. So that
was kind of my second part of this, okay?
And then, Aiden,
Mhm. I heard a call that you were in. And in the course of this
call, you did a few things, okay?
The most
serious of which, even if I think it was an incredibly edgy joke
still, is you talked about and murdering Leo Conroy's wife. Did
I say I was I I don't think I said that I I said
Okay, I gave him this. I again
Okay. You Okay, well let's Okay, listen. It's one of those things
where it's like he didn't say rape. He he didn't say rape. And
I actually don't think he meant
But it's like it's one of those things where it's like
it's it's just rough cuz I understand not wanting that narrative
to persist,
but also it's like
how do you how do you stop arguing every tiny little point? >> want
to be a debate
>> I'm not trying to I'm not trying to be a debate person.
It's just who I am. No, I'm not trying to We can do this, okay?
You talked about going to Leo Conroy's house to have sex with
his wife, okay?
Yes. You said and you meant we as a
Yes. Do you think you No, none of us had the intention to do
that. Okay. Okay.
If you all went to Leo Conroy's house, right? And you all tried
to have sex with Leo Conroy's wife, do you think that she would
meaningfully consent to have sex with each one of you? Yes or
Uh under the stipulation of my repeated joke that he's a and
she [__] everyone else, yes. Okay.
But in reality, outside of your kind of, you know, hypothetical
>> Yeah, in in reality, if this wasn't some like off-color
drunken joke that is like plays into a theme of jokes I've repeatedly
made where it's consensual,
Uh sure. Um but obviously
I again
I think this is the Brandon Buckingham Sneako hypothetical
that is oh no, hold on. False rape Wait, wait, wait, wait, [clears throat]
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Uh-oh.
Did Chud comment on it?
A quick summary of some of the other points without going and
watching all the video now, okay? So just to give you an update
if you're not aware. Oh also, he yeah, oh sorry, that's another
important point. I think it maybe mentions it here, but um he
he pushed a false allegation against Brandon Buckingham.
Because Sneako and Brandon Buckingham have beef and in the course
of that, Sneako completely mischaracterized something that happened
Oh no. and you know, acted like
uh Brandon Buckingham was like some sort of assaulter or was
going to assault someone or assault someone. And this in praise
of shadow guys just
Oh no, cuz it's one-to-one with that situation, right?
It is I'm sorry, it is literally like one-to-one with that situation.
So in terms of debate work, okay? I do think it is that exact
Um and realistically, no matter what Aiden's mindset is, no matter
how much he wants to ruin these people's lives, that actually
doesn't change whether you calling his wife a who will everybody
else, right? No, no, no, not including the dogs. Has nothing
to do with the The core criticism is you are calling this woman
a you're calling her husband
and you're saying me and the boys going to run a train on this
That isn't saying you're going to them and when it's Brandon
Buckingham saying it to Sneako, Chud appears to believe that
that is wild to call it that is a allegation. It's a total mischaracterization
to call it So, I'm just saying in this case I think this is one
to one where Aiden literally laid out the exact same criteria.
Uh we call his wife a sorry, we call him a we call his wife a
we me and the boys going to roll up, right? Me and the boys going
to roll up and and run a train on this [__] Cuz he
does say like gang we're going to all go her, yeah? So, I I think
Aiden's fine there. Now, that's the only defense I need to do,
okay?
And I'll reiterate that I do not believe
I do not believe that Chud thinks that serious that they're going
to roll up and this woman or something and I don't think it has
to do with the doc stuff. I think all this points in a direction
which by the way I agree with Chud's overall diagnosis that this
points in a direction that he's way over the line. That Aiden
is way over the line on all these comments that he is clearly
obsessed. He's clearly breaking his own principles to go after
this guy. I just think in this case Chud's actually wrong with
this exact like characterization and it's not one he would apply
in other cases. So, it a bit is what it is, okay?
It is what it is. >> be taken in isolation. I get why it
would be. It's not that serious. >> trying to get something
clear here. I'm trying to establish that you were threatening
to Leo K
>> where it isn't a threat. You're literally calling this
guy a whose wife everybody will will literally have a train run
on her by as many guys as possible the second he's like a little
bit out of earshot. There's obviously a context you could set
up there for that joke. And I think Aiden says he set that up
here. Anyway, that's all Trust me, none of this helps Aiden.
I'm just doing the little gay litigations that he would do otherwise
that he would like do and they're irrelevant to his overall guilt,
but they're they're the ways he's like saying oh, I want to argue
on this. I'm just doing it for him so he doesn't have But you
did threaten to because you spoke about you and we, whoever we
is, going to the house and the reality is if you wrote to Like
the Sam Hyde threat to Hasan is kind of insane.
Yeah, sure. But again, that's not this thing. >> Leo K
Anvoy's house and you tried I'm not Wait, I'm not saying that
Aiden didn't say he wanted to go there and them that he wasn't
talking about them. He did do that. Yeah, you shouldn't do that.
Leo K Anvoy's wife, okay? She would likely not consent to that
which would be wouldn't
I wasn't thinking about at the time and I think I explicitly
clarified that when someone else used that word in the car which
is why I'm asking whoever Leo K Anvoy is recording that.
>> Dude, boy Aiden's voice cracks are just killing me.
Just admit the whole thing. Just admit it, okay? That regardless
of how you're spinning it, you talking about we going round to
Leo K Anvoy's house and his wife, if that were to happen, that
would be because she would be highly unlikely to consent, right?
If I was to do that in real life, sure. But in my hypothetical
joke world, no. That was >> So, you were threatening to
Leo K Anvoy's wife even in a joking way. You were jokingly threatened
to Leo K Anvoy's wife. Yes, you were. >> I didn't. You
were jokingly threatened to Leo K Anvoy's wife. You were because
if you went round there she wouldn't consent. That would make
it If it was to actually be executed in reality, maybe. But I
wasn't thinking about its execution in reality cuz it was a joke.
It was a joke. But I'm saying I'm putting that in there. You're
joking
The the joke like part of the joke is that she would consent,
right? That's part of the joke. You're like denigrating this
guy's manhood. You're a
loser whose wife will any other guy, whose wife would be psyched
if me and the boys rolled up and ran a train on her cuz she would
get a little bit of like actually solid for once in her life.
That's like that's the whole point. I've actually never heard
the joke. Um
The well, it's it's in the leak call. But I'm I'm probably not
going to go back and listen to it again. He he says like we we
should go and Leo K Anvoy's wife while in a group call, right?
>> about threatening to Leo K Anvoy's wife. Even though
you're not using those words, it would be you're threatening
This is a such a pedantic point. >> Yeah, because nobody
is getting it clear here. I'm not going to lie to you. I wasn't
thinking that. That wasn't my intention. If executed in reality
I think for this whole thing
for this whole thing
the clear problematic thing to me is him talking about fabricating
and then the the rest of the Discord participating in fabricating
those threats to like get her fired from her job. Fabricating
those details the the ice support or something get her fired
from her job. That's like way worse. I don't know why Chud decided
to stand in the the thing. >> Your intention is you have
issued a threat to Leo K Anvoy's wife regardless of what your
intent is when you think it all through. I made Uh yeah, and
he should he should just already dude, he's going to be so pedantic
again. I remember his response to this. It is that um Chud did
exactly what he criticized Dickers of. The anybody saying they'll
somebody's wives is actually saying they want to them. Um well,
hold on Let It Just Gamer. The train thing is a little different.
I I don't think it's like insane. I understand it. I understand
the people who hear that they go oh, what the [__]
I do get it. It's just like there's like I understand the mentality
of Aiden or the mentality of somebody who's saying the [__]
more. No, I made a joke about her and her in the VC, yeah. >> Okay.
I didn't know it would be fundamentally you were joking about
threatening to and Leo K Anvoy's wife. What does that look like
to people? >> isn't there. But yeah.
Yeah, like how how possible the threat is is actually important.
So, that one seems less important to me. Like freeze drying goat
cado and carving her up to get her disembodied womb to put into
a Chinese takeout box. That's like you know, a level of specificity
Perry does this to make a joke that is like unbelievable, right?
That is the whole point. That's again why the life root that's
a Perry joke. That's a Perry joke. Perry said that. Hold on.
Wait, Perry that Perry joke is fantastic. Hold on. Wait, maybe
I think Queenman sent me a bunch of streamables for this. Hold
on. Give me a second.
Um where's the where's the they take an Uber. Anyway, so then
we get an Uber get an Uber guys and we had two club that's played
really good music. I think it's called the Lexington. I'm pretty
sure. In the Uber, what do we talk about in the Uber? So, but
you see it do you see it guys? So, so we have Dickers This is
their layout in the Uber. is on his phone. Both of you are He's
on his phone. Listen to the video. really drunk, right? He got
really drunk. He was like [__] fam. We weren't even
sure if Aiden would be able to come with us to the club. Um and
so in the Uber, Aiden's just sitting there sort of like like
this like staring off to the middle distance listening once again
to Beethoven and also Kanye West. Also Kanye West. Oh, uh Aiden
did a whole bit in the club where he held up his phone showing
he was listening to Beethoven instead of the club music. Um I
don't know. I don't know if that's a it's a funny bit if it's
a bit. But I don't know how much he's like doing the Darius thing.
I think all of his socially awkward I'm like better than you
bits are a Darius bit, but instead of like hitting on women and
then saying it's a joke when people call it cringe or people
don't like it, he literally does the he does like the I'm into
too intellectual for this bit and then when people are like oh
you're cringe and gay, he's like oh it was a joke though. I don't
know the I don't know the exact details but he ends up being
like um he's like saying this is a cringe sometimes but he's
like oh yeah I'm being annoying. whatever at some point who brings
up GoatKato? Who brings up GoatKato? I think Queen brings up
I think Queen brings up GoatKato and GoatKato I don't know we
basically make fun of um Aiden. He calls her GoatKato he calls
her GoatKato. I say people don't really get this this is quite
avant-garde. We should um grab GoatKato
cut her up and put her womb in one of those takeout boxes. That's
what I say. That's my contribution to this bit where
demean GoatKato in front of Aiden in order to annoy Aiden is
I said that we should we should grab GoatKato
dry her using salt.
I remember it was I asked Queen. So if we had to murder
GoatKato
do you think we should freeze dry her or or salt and cure her?
How do you think we should store our GoatKato? And then I also
remember that Queen said but then I said um Oh and the best part
don't spoil the best part. Don't don't talk about what happens.
I told it's it's hypothetical guys. I just about the actual behavior.
And then I said we should get one of those takeout boxes like
they like those plastic papery takeout boxes and it's just GoatKato's
womb. It's just GoatKato's just GoatKato's. And I just I like
that image. I like
the image.
I'm hoping [snorts] they got [laughter] the takeout box and it's
an disembodied I think that's quite humorous. I think that's
quite humorous. Everyone was getting annoyed. I think people
I you know Dickers and uh whatever was saying dude you're safe
for saying this with the Uber driver exactly behind me. Um but
it was
I just love like the idea that you'd what you in like in some
like reality TV show okay you'd be watching Perry tell this story
and then the camera like as he's finishing up the story slowly
pans back to this Uber driver who's just horrified like gripping
the wheel listen to this psychopath talk about cutting up this
20-year-old woman in the back of the in the back of the cab.
It'd be so funny.
It's all a joke. It's all a joke.
Yeah this is the same GoatKato that you would find if you looked
up GoatKato online. Anyway.
Yeah Perry Perry is like I'm starting to think he's got like
a sense of humor. Honestly I don't know why he does the I feel
like he's just really horny to get popular or something. I don't
know why he does like the overt lying thing.
He's got like a sense of humor where he could make all of this
work really well but like getting into like overtly lying about
people is just weird and like sort of almost jeopardize what
he's doing. I like the Brandon Buckingham thing although it's
kind of funny now
that was weird to me. It's just a little weird. But his sense
of humor I think he could go far as a streamer with a sense of
humor. I think there's something there. Except I also think he's
like Sam Hyde in that the insanity is there legitimately and
there's a chance that we find out Perry like beat up and disembodied
like a 16-year-old
in like a couple years.
Like there there is legitimate insanity there too which is scary
in some ways. So how do you think that sounds?
Um if it was like sounds bad but I'm sure if you were to record
most of my jokes when I'm drunk I'd look horrible. >> Okay
we need to look at the totality of what's going on here don't
we because I would agree with you if you when you were drunk
made one joke about someone's wife or having to someone's wife
or someone's wife I could see that as an insane unhinged that
you're saying. But we need to take it in the context of you saying
that in the call okay and on top of that as well you have been
spreading his wife's docs. Yeah so the the latter I agree with
and I can understand why you would perceive it the way you do
with the evidence and aggregation. I'm just telling you what
I think happened. Um but I I'm not saying that you're like delusional
for thinking this right? Sure but what I'm saying is whilst I
do not believe you're going to go buy a rifle and go round with
the squad to Leah Conway's house. Yeah I don't think I'd ever
let Perry anywhere near my property. I think
I I feel like
would not share a like an Airbnb or anything with Perry. I would
just not Okay [laughter] right the fact that you've got a docs
makes it less likely to be a joke than if you didn't.
Sure less likely if you're an outside observer and you perceived
it that way. Okay right Aiden who do you think the most people
are looking at this right? Is it your So so so wait So that's
why you're I agree with you wait wait if you're if the argument
is they would perceive it this way we agree. Okay so then your
career is bro because how the are you going to be able to get
people on board? What community are you going to draw
Aiden you've made unsavory jokes about and people have credibly
Wait hold on. People have accused you of doxing. He actually
did the doxing himself. He can't quite do it. There's something
here there's like a tenuous almost thing here it's like you've
made unsavory jokes about who will ever whoever will you draw
from? He's like probably still your community probably still
the your community I think. You made incredibly unsavory jokes
about this
Unforgivable jokes.
There is the in totality thing is kind of true here. I just think
it's it seems like over the there's parts of part of the way
it's like over the line. But in totality I think the doxing stand
stands on its own. The doxing and pressuring this guy like explicitly
the docs information is obtained you you let him know that you
have the docs information to pressure him into talking to you
and you continue to leak tidbits about his wife until you finally
get drunk and leak everything about his wife right? That Yeah
yeah yeah the but the thing doesn't matter. The thing's irrelevant.
The thing's just being used as a cudgel. It's literally you obtained
docs information about his wife. You were taunting him that you
had docs information about his wife. You were leaking tidbits
of docs information about his wife and then you got drunk and
leaked all of the docs information you had about his wife.
Like that's bad. That's really really bad. That is what makes
you radioactive. You're you're going after this guy's wife for
not talking to you and you're justifying it under the the idea
that she supports him.
You have now greenlit everybody around you. You've that's what
makes you radioactive. That's what makes this argument a little
bit right? But for some reason he's just continued to go you
made threats you made threats you made threats. And he's like
really leaning on it for some reason. I just don't understand.
Like that is so low grade to compared to all of the other information
and he's just like he's just making it he's just ego checking
it to get it Like it's just that I'm the bigger creator it's
my audience you respect me.
It's like the weakest way you can make this argument. He's still
he's still broadly correct by the way just the way he's making
the argument I have like slight criticism. >> just explain
I made like a drunken off-color joke uh like I mean that would
probably be it um people aren't willing to like
look at the context I I then that's fine they could go their
own separate way. So do you know what I would actually agree
that if we stopped there as extreme as the joke is okay
I reckon that you might be able to get away with it being like
an off-color joke okay? Look what I show Speed said to a woman
on stream he actually threatened directly to her on stream is
one of the most popular stream like I'm not saying that's what
I mean. Absolutely insane whataboutism right here that's not
even the biggest problem. I don't know why you would bring Speed
up. One Speed didn't say we're going to go this woman. He said
if we're the last two people on Earth who going to stop me? Who
going to The hypothetical with Speed is like so one that doesn't
exist or if it does exist none of us care. Like he's saying yeah
if it was just me and you nobody would stop me cuz I wouldn't
feel the pressure of society to her. Which really I was going
to make a joke that Chud would get along with but I'm not going
to I'm not going to be racist right now. Also Lil Bro isn't Speed.
Lil Bro isn't Speed sure.
I I I don't think that because Speed wasn't Speed when he did
that right? I don't know if Speed was quite Speed yet when he
did that. I think Speed got kind of for that didn't he? Like
Speed wasn't the absolute unstoppable Jesus of an entire community
at that point. He was like stop he was like somewhat touchable
at that point.
Aiden is on Speed also true. Yeah he got in trouble when it happened.
But he wasn't he wasn't the size he is If I guarantee you if
Speed was the current day Speed
and Twitch could have made that decision like where he is right
now
I think they let it go. Get 50k live then on Twitch?
Bro he he has way higher live numbers on YouTube now. He wasn't
like the cultural movement he is now. I'm going to be not even
close. I'm still going to be a 100 viewers but I don't think
anything's going to substantially change over that. I can get
if you want to personally cut ties or if anyone else would
but I mean I I'm
Imagine thinking he's on par with Speed.
I don't think he's on par with Speed. I'm saying when I when
you say he's not Speed it's like Speed can't be touched now.
I that's how I see it. Of course Aiden's not close to I Show
Speed. But then you're just saying that like well
don't expect the same treatment as other
Kind of flies in the face of what most people believe. >> going
to own it and I I think I could probably Although that's true
move on as long as the behavior doesn't repeat itself. Okay,
well any Wait, do you think hold on? Why do you guys think I'm
arguing he's close to
That's not what I said. I argued a completely different point.
It's It's fine, but it's It's It's giving an example of people
not condemning the content the conduct or something he thinks,
but again
it's really stupid because Speed was condemned heavily, was permanently
banned from Twitch, was actually kind of ruined for that conduct.
Any case, I think maybe that might be true if we stop there.
But then we get to the worst most egregious part of this. Okay?
You were joking
about engaging
in life ruination of Leo Convoy's wife. Yeah, so and yeah, that
was also like an off-color joke that looks bad out of Yep. Okay.
Well, I would say >> no, no, no. It looks really bad in
the context we see.
Unless for some reason like 60 seconds after the comments were
made you went, "Hey, whoever told me that they're going to go
find this woman's LinkedIn, you're totally deranged and you're
banned from this community now." Which I don't think >> I
don't believe that was just a joke and I think you have seriously
considered this. And with you having a doxx and coming up with
the specificity of what you could do
I think that you're like on the precipice of engaging in life
ruination. And to me this is >> Okay, thank god. Oh my
god, it's an actual argument.
It's an actual Oh, Chud, thank you. Thank you. I knew he could
get there. >> But in as when Flamenco this is very similar
at least as to when Flamenco was talking about calling Xander
Hall's wife. Uh sorry, brother. So all right, so just to just
so we can go back to Do you not think that the lash You don't
think the lash was it like the last thing was a joke? Well, the
thing is I don't really know because I would
Um say if you just said in itself, "I'm going to do this and
ruin Leo Convoy's life, right?" I would say, "Oh, that's probably
a joke." But now I've got a lot more context that means I don't
really know and my concern is that you are like one step away
from doing it. And if you get drunk and are willing to engage
in this sort of behavior
like could you take the next step, you know? Would you be there
engaging in life ruination?
Because maybe you're not quite there yet, but this is what I'm
saying. You're on the precipice. You're at the
I think you're consistently threatening and talking about it
and you get drunk and then you actually started doxxing this
person. Like Like this is a good argument This is a way better
argument, right? You clearly have wanted to pressure this guy.
You clearly wanted to use his wife as leverage the entire
Um and then you started like actually doing You started like
actually putting information out there that puts them under threat.
Like I believe Beckett reveals this at some point. But Leo Convoy's
been swatted twice. Like putting more information out there about
him and his wife, there are clearly people probably some of whom
you could reasonably believe are lurking in your Discord. Not
that you can do anything about that, but they probably are lurking
in your Discord who would be willing to engage in actual IRL
stuff against Leo Convoy or his wife. So when you post that [__]
you are you are participating in it, right? It's crazy. You specifically
say what changed your mind when you first heard it first heard
it about why he shouldn't cover Convoy anymore. Specifically,
I literally have just like talked back and forth with people
and I do believe I just I didn't lend a lot of credence to it.
Maybe it's a little bit of bias on my part, but I do think
this whole thing that like he's just displayed like a very diseased
mindset with regards to this guy and he is a and the most important
piece here is he has done an act which is outside of his stated
principles
because of his emotional um his emotion his emotional state with
regards to this person, right? And I also was waiting to hear
like more details of exactly how he doxxed the person, waiting
for some of the truthiness of the claims to settle. Like when
he said, "I have no idea." That's like a fake thing with regards
to the occupation cuz I had no idea where she worked. I had to
wait for that to like come down a bit and and get settled out.
And now that I know it for a fact, it's like, "Okay, okay, I
got it."
Um I thought you knew that when you talked about it. Well, I
said I've had conversations with people and I've just like had
the arguments in a little more detail. It's not like one specific
argument changed my mind. It's just like me rethinking it and
running it in my mind with like other situations. Literally just
like letting it marinate in my own head over time. I can't say
you know like one piece that significantly changed. It was like
kind of on the line. And I do agree he can still post content
on him. I think he shouldn't. I think he shouldn't cuz there
are other side tangent arguments to this, right? That like as
he continues to go after Leo Convoy, I do think it's difficult
for other people to engage with him. I do. Cuz he's he's now
doxxed this guy who has apparently like harassed IRL or or contacted
IRL people who are the object of his content. Like and there
there was a whole bunch of people in this art commentary community
who engage in this kind of behavior who go who take it like too
far. There's like just a a whole lot going on here where I I
think it would be better for him if he didn't cover this guy.
I I think it would just be better for him. Yeah.
Um and again, I I don't think I'd make this claim because I if
he hadn't actually crossed the line. Right? If it was just rhetoric,
if he was just joking with the homies while he was drunk in a
big VC
I could let that all go, but obviously it's preceded by him crossing
the line very explicitly. It's like low-tier furry right? I believe
that. And it's one small step when you've done it. It could be
a drunken night that you decide to do it. And you also threatened
to engage in life ruination in regards to Perry as well. That
was That is a That was so much more mild than any joke Perry
has ever told. I'll agree with your perception. Perry's jokes
is >> Then you shouldn't care about mine.
I didn't
>> There's like a thing where Perry is talking about very
specific explicit stuff he'd have to do in real life that it's
unreasonable to suspect he'd ever undertake. Whereas like when
Aiden makes a joke he's like, "I'm going to link a clip compilation
to employers."
It's like, "Well, that takes no effort. You could do that at
the drop of a hat." Like that's the problem with your threat
is your threat is you could do that at the drop of a hat. It's
like a reasonably a reasonably possible threat. Perry's stuff
is all like absurdity, >> On that one, not at all. I get
Leo's wife cuz I actually spread her doxx. Perry is irrelevant
in terms of talking about your conduct. Okay? Yeah, but the just
I don't care about Perry. I do not want to talk about Perry because
I'm >> bring Then don't bring it up. I'm No, I'm bringing
it up because you were talking about clipping details from his
stream and sending them to every employer with his name.
I said every employer in the country of Malta, right? Obviously
I can't do that. That's a joke. It Okay.
Again, it's like I think
the thing here is I do think that that part is probably a joke.
Again, Aiden's shown that he will like the
of these jokes   he's willing to go in that direction.
Okay. In and of itself it's a joke. Yeah. The country of Malta,
which is Is Malta not basically just a city? Like one city on
an island. How Hold on. Popu-
of Malta. Population of Malta is
So well
not like not eminently possible
it's not like it's totally impossible, right? It's like it's
not that insane. Right? But again, I'm assuming you do know what
his real name is because you've met him in real life. Okay? But
you have got more, okay, in that in having at least his first
name and a
You're tweaking.
Well, how many of the jobs there are like country Malta? I'm
saying that I don't think he'd send it to everybody. I think
he'd send it to like multiple employers. I think I think it was
legitimately like not really a joke. I think he was like trying
to I I think
I've seen a lot of evidence that Aiden likes to make threats
that put pressure on people to stop doing what he doesn't like.
That he thinks that that's like based. I do I do think that's
true.
what it looks like to actually engage in the threat that you're
making meaning that the likelihood of it ever being a joke is
lower. I'm not saying you're definitively going to do it, right?
But I'm saying that to many outside observers you look like a
totally deranged unhinged freak that is one step away from engaging
in strategies that are pretty much conclusively
criticized, disagreed with, including on the most extreme places
on the internet like Kiwi Farms. Even Kiwi Farms would take issue
with your conduct.
So I mean I don't necessarily know like
how I can argue again like the statement I'm going to go and
do something. I don't know how I can argue against that other
than not doing it. >> no. Wait a second, Aiden. You [__]
Bro, debate you're
dude. Okay? Well, yeah, I don't The point isn't The point is
not that I think you're definitively going to do it. Okay? The
point is there is now a reasonable perception that you're going
to engage in that behavior that is extremely destructive to your
career and you would only need to look at someone like Flamenco
to see the consequences long-term of doing this sort of thing.
It could It is a complete credibility r- Your credibility is
r- It's in the toilet. It's dirt. And it wasn't very good as
it was cuz of your obsession with Leo Convoy. Go.
He what? Bro, what's going on in the wick panel? Is there a struggle
session with Pesco? Actually, these anti-fans are really
Is that really happening?
Maybe we'll check it out after the fact. There's apparently We'll
We'll check it out in just a little bit. We'll check it out after
this. >> Flamenco did just like get complete forgiven by
everyone after the I know like it's like that's not like you're
be a good standard cuz people didn't wait too long. The only
reason he got forgiveness is cuz Augie sweat for him. And there's
no one left to sweep for >> have this discussion. You cannot
win this war. You cannot win this war, Aiden, okay? You're [__]
He took this from HolyXGrail in the chat. Uh HolyXGrail said
this and then Chud literally paused and said,
"Uh you I'm going to take that and use it later." I'm not trying
I'm not trying
I've conceded on what I I conceded on what I believed I've done.
Um I've refuted what I did have and you seem to accept that the
things that I'm arguing were jokes were jokes and it seems like
we agree that other people wouldn't perceive it as such.
>> I do not agree based on the totality of it that these
are definitively jokes, okay? Because the problem is >> you
agreed that you personally thought the on all that [__]
was Okay.
Hold on. Obviously Okay, let me clarify. Obviously, do I think
there's a significant chance of you going and Leokun was wife?
No. Do I think there's a significant chance of you going and
doing life urination? Well, no, right? But that is also a bias
on my part because I would not have thought you'd have got to
the step that you are now a few months ago. So, I'm looking at
this and I'm thinking surely Aiden wouldn't do something like
that. But if you'd have asked me like 4 months ago, would Aiden
be spreading someone's docs and talking about doing life urination
as a joke? I'd be like, "Nah, that's not the kind of thing Aiden
would do." And now you have. So, why would I now think >> urination
is a joke I would, but the other [__] out. You're
right.
Okay. So, the problem is now is I'm thinking you're one step
away from that. You're one drunken night away from doing the
sort of behavior, okay? And you've already made some effort to
collect the tools. Perhaps the docs is just for something else
for a laugh, but you're already collecting tools to facilitate
the action that you know you could potentially engage in. Yeah,
well I wasn't I wasn't I I just like searched up on it and then
sent a screen shot
This is why like This is why I can only get so angry at Chud,
okay? Cuz now he's like trying to make actual
right? Trying to make actual arguments.
And Aiden just didn't care, didn't >> planning on actually
doing anything with that and those jokes were off-colored and
I'm obviously not going to do that, so Well, no, no, cuz that's
not true. But wait. Okay, it might be obvious to you that you're
not going to do it cuz you know inside your own head, but to
everyone else it is not obvious that oh, you're definitely not
going to do life
And I think >> I'm sorry they feel that way. Okay, but
the thing is it's not about sorry they feel that way. I'm pointing
out to you your behavior has put you in the category of art commentary
community local, okay? And that's where you are now and you're
not getting out of that. That's it. It's done. Especially combined
with other comments about your conduct in the social situation,
the goat catto stuff which we can talk about if you want. All
of this means that you are now an ACC local. Yeah, I mean the
the other stuff was well for the liar's wife [__]
Like I like that was all that [__] was completely
unnecessary, but I mean Yeah, I uh I just like I agree that I
[__] up by spreading that
Yeah, I How's Leokun doing now? How's Leokun doing now? You said
he was forgiven. How's he getting on now?
No, over this He wasn't forgiven over the you know, like
obviously.
Um and he completely crashed out and like was really upset. So,
as long as you're not So, as long as you're not You I think you'd
be okay. Well, no, that's multi-faceted as I was just like saying
like there was also like the response which I think I was kind
of beginning to indicate like some aspects of in regards to like
the constant argumentation and Um but I think I came around.
Uh so, I mean yeah. Okay, dude. Well, in any case, um I just
think that you have completely and
been destroyed all of your credibility with anyone that matters
for the sake of placating a bunch of Discord over your obsession
with Leokun boy. We can talk about that as well. Why are you
obsessed with Leokun boy?
Yeah, so Leokun boy encouraged a minor
Again, just pretty provably getting outside of his principles,
right? It's a crazy some of themselves. Um he under the threat
of contacting their families got mentally vulnerable disabled
adults into calls where he repeatedly threatened them. Um and
people who were so mentally disabled they were under >> you're
talking about this, dude, right? Well, cuz I think it's ridicu
I think it's sweep ridiculous. I'm some From Okay, you're I'm
not sweeping, right? Because I don't give a [__]
about any of this. It sounds really terrible. Leokun is a terrible
person. No, we do have to talk about it because I'm saying this
is your problem. You've become obsessed with the minutia of the
[__] drama in the art commentary community. You're
responding to a tweet of Leokun boy when he's showing a picture
of a 57 subscriber YouTube channel. This is who your nemesis
is. Some
fat lion man who's got a fake family, right? He's the father
of the art commentary community and you've made this guy your
enemy and you have gone down the spiral. You stared into the
abyss of the art commentary community for too long. You've become
obsessed with Leokun boy only to your detriment. >> Leokun
boy got He does seem really
There's like a lot of weird details that go into this guy.
I'll probably not >> Look at where you are now. Look at
where you are now on the precipice of life urination of someone
else off the back of your obsession with this guy. Um I mean
I
I think like everything I've said about him stands. Um It doesn't
matter what the analysis about him is. It's about the obsession
that you've got with him. Every single stream talking about this
guy from what I understand, okay? Every new stream some new
Well, then there's a lot of [__] to
Okay, no, there isn't. There only is if you want to cultivate
a community of ACC
who will sit on a call with you and cheer you on Leokun boy A-logs
that will cheer you on as you talk about murdering and doing
life urination of his wife where any sensible person would say
to >> was Leokun joking private not on the streams. Okay,
that's irrelevant. Anything that happens on the internet, dude.
You have fallen so far, dude. It is disgraceful, bro. You know
that
You No, you're not being Okay. You're acting reasonable, right?
But you're not Chud overreacting. Um his overreaction to the
comments were way too much, like way way way too much. I think
they were very absurd. But he he finally got into like the life
urination stuff which is probably more within Aiden's capability.
His His Discord members were actively like cheering this on and
actively like trying to participate with him in terms of like
contacting her employer. That's pretty bad. It's all recorded
as well. That's pretty rough. Um so, that that stuff is getting
better. >> know that anything that you do on the internet
has a very thin veil of uh you know, obstruction on it and it
could be taken off at any moment. So, the idea that you did it
in a private call when others were present is irrelevant. That
is a massive risk of doing that and it's now become public.
Well, yeah. Uh I I make really off-colored
Again, I do think
I think that the jokes lead us in a direction of
I don't know. I don't know how to say this cuz like I've definitely
been in VCs with like 30 people where someone who's a creator
makes like an off-color joke. Then I wouldn't hold against them
as if it's like their real opinion, right? Even if they really
didn't like the person, I feel like this bar is not one I'm willing
to concede immediately cuz I feel like I can think of examples
of people who I don't think are at risk of doing this kind of
behavior who would make these kinds of jokes,
Um I do think the doxing stuff changes that slightly, but it's
really like to me the the really bad conduct is again
obtaining the information, using it to pressure, right? Using
it to pressure Leokun boy by referencing it, by talking about
using it, and then eventually you end up dropping it. That's
like all you need. That's all of the condemnation is there. The
only The only way you need more than that is that you basically
like don't feel like that's already enough.
I do I do think the one thing where the community's participating
makes the
the thing about like getting her fired a little more tangible,
a little more weird. But again, like the joke Dude, I'm not going
to I can't I can't possibly like say that's over the line given
the communities, right? It's It's
Even when you attach it to all the other stuff, I still can't
possibly say that I think that's real or over the line. >> jokes
in private and [__] and this one was like particularly
bad cuz I actually did do something bad in relation to this >> back
to it's just jokes. It's about the perception from the public
before it's taken together. How do you think the average person
If the average person looked at this from this community looked
at this, how would they perceive you? What would they think about
you?
Um probably like uh pretty badly right now. Uh I I guess. They
would think, "Oh my god." I can tell you cuz I've seen it in
chat. "Oh my god, it's Flamenco 2.0. Oh my god, he's fallen off
so bad. I can't believe he's This is crazy."
It's not just a bad look. Catastrophic. This is catastrophic.
This Your credibility is ruined forever. No one will take you
seriously ever again. No one is going to listen to anything
I just Again, like a total overreaction.
I get that it feels really good. It feels like really righteous
to go in on someone like this. But again, it's just like way
over the
Like bro, I I don't know if Chud knows this, but like in society
we actually like don't even just kill murderers and say they
can't do anything again. And Aiden's nowhere near that, right?
Like I It's just so over the top. It's It's a lot. >> thing
you say. And the tragic thing for you with your obsession, no
one's going to listen to anything you've got to say about Leo
Convoy anymore because you've painted yourself into >> people
would be I'm sorry. It's like in my points, you don't need to
like me, you don't need to trust me cuz I just bring up evidence
of his own words. Okay, it doesn't matter about the evidence,
bro. People don't give a You are going to >> would it matter
if I'm a good person or not be relevant? Like Well, it's not
about you being a good person. It's about the perception of you
and your credibility. Credibility matters if you want to do what
you're trying to do and your credibility is shot to bits. Credibility matters
if I need you trusting my word. You don't have to. You could
assume I'm lying about everything. Just look at the evidence.
Okay, but the problem is, okay, you are not going to be able
to cultivate a community of people By the way, I think I think
this idea
I think this idea is like incredibly
and it just reinforces like some of the worst elements of humanity.
Like this uh how do I explain it? There's like something here
where it's again, it's like too easy to destroy trust in people
and like way too hard to build it. That like it's very easy to
just say that that somebody's had their trust destroyed. There's
like
I just keep seeing the like I see glimmers, like edges of there's
like a underlying thesis here that is like actually good. No,
it's not just this. It's like
Like I think this leads to people not trusting someone like um
Was it Sinead O'Connor that tried talking about like in Hollywood
for a long time? And she was like really eccentric and was was
she with the Catholic Church? It was the Catholic Church, right?
And like people just like her credibility got destroyed and it's
like I think you should be willing to listen to people with low
credit like who you think have lost their um credibility or something.
I think you should be willing to like you should be willing to
look at that stuff and I think it's basically
it nobody wants to make the actual argument which is um I don't
have time to look at very much stuff. I'm a busy
I don't want to listen to you because I think there's like a
tiny reason in terms of like the heuristic that I shouldn't have
to listen to you, that I could like and and like there's so much
information happening in my life that I could just ignore like
a lot of it and so you fit in that heuristic. It's not that your
credibility's destroyed, it's not that you're like never trustable
and stuff. It's literally I'm going to write you off because
then I don't have to pay attention and that makes my life easier.
Is like the way people actually think about it. But it's like
but we have to like moralize it, we have to make it like you're
it's justified. I'm totally I'm totally justified in never ever
listening to you again. It's like no, you're just like making
your life slightly easier is probably what's happening. Nobody
wants some insane doxing in the community. I think that's the
point overall. Um yeah. Yeah, I think
the doxing probably does cross the line. I do not like the arguments
that people are like oh well um
Yeah, the doxing probably does cross the line. I think it would
be rough to have Aiden on for a lot of stuff at this
Like it's just brutal that it's brutal that he went and did this.
Like that probably is I I think if anything my bias has been
like well, I'm willing to give him the benefit of the doubt for
a little bit but like it seems like we've sort of resolved this
and he started dumping this doxing information. He was threatening
the person with the doxing
and like that probably is enough to just be like yeah, I don't
think we do stuff with Aiden anymore.
I think you need to do to evaluation the impact of burning that
trust. Why do I need to believe anything Aiden says? You don't.
And but you never did.
Yeah, well, I think there's like a different you should be careful
with that, okay? Cuz that that could be like well, if I accidentally
Google someone and their information comes up. Right? If I like
Google a name and their full like doxing comes up or something.
Like that's a little different. But that's I guess no malice
in that, right? Pretty hard for maybe maybe it's fine because
of the malice element of doxing.
Yeah. No, no, no, it's probably fine cuz of the malice element.
It's probably included what you said.
yeah, I'm just trying to think. But there are like ways you could
accidentally post someone's information but it's not the same.
Yeah, that's probably fair.
Not even being confrontational but how do you say this and then
be okay with continuing to have Lav on stream? I don't know.
I guess just time. After time, I feel like some of the crimes
just kind of like she admits it
it goes away.
Um I I think Lav is like a broadly like
person who does this like in moments of like raging out which
is not good and maybe there's an argument you shouldn't have
her on stream because of that. But with with Aiden it's like
again, just the stated malice, the stated like provable malice,
the planning, the I'm going to like twist the screws on this
guy to like make him more uncomfortable over time to build this
up to like actually [__] with him and hopefully he'll
talk to me. It's like it is it is explicitly
No, I'm saying there's there's both. You have both with Aiden.
Was he planning really? Yes. Yes, when Aiden references the information,
when he taunts Leo Convoy with it, Leo Convoy with it right on
Twitter. I do think that is maliciously using that information
already. Yeah, ultimately it's also possible that Aiden is just
funny enough, cool enough that people will have him on even if
he's totally crazy. But planning? Uh I I believe there are allegations
of planning, Pilkington, yes. That it that he said he was going
to use this information to continue to make Leo Convoy uncomfortable
until he would talk to him. I think that is a plan. Like I I
believe Dickers said that that Aiden was saying I'm going to
keep going after his wife, I'm going to keep pressuring his wife
with this stuff until he feels like he's going to until he's
ready to talk to me.
I do believe unless I'm mistaken but I think that is correct
for what Dickers was saying, okay? And so that element is like
it's really bad. That's why even the leaks, I'm just like dude,
I I think you had it before the leaks. It just took a while of
like marinating the information, hearing people talk about it,
um hearing other people confirm different elements and then there's
been like a lot of jokes mixed in here like the whole Cocotama
thing. That I just I'm I just needed to like let it settle for
a little bit. That that is a problem with doing like a stream
that's like 8 hours a day nearly every day of the week is like
I sometimes you need to sit down and like really walk through
stuff and compare it to other situations and there's like an
element of comedy going on here. There's an element of trying
to entertain that kind of prevents that in the moment. You do
need to like sit down and collect your thoughts on things to
come to like a strong determination.
All right, see you later. Have a good night. I think that's that's
like a thing that happened so
I won't always have the right call in the moment. I don't have
a perfect like active mental map of my like principles
at all times that I can immediately
like conjure. I think I have a better better like idea of that
than most people but sometimes you do need to think about like
counter examples. Emotions get in the way sometimes. >> people
that have got broad interest in what you're doing, right? Because
you have cultivated a community of Discord to only care about
drama that they feel close to because they've got nothing going
on in their lives and then they're the kinds of people that will
hop in a call with you and say things and get you to do things
against your better judgment like drunkenly crash out and joke
Hold on. I should I should actually shill. Guys, if you like
the content, go ahead follow on every platform, join the Discord,
Uh gift a couple subs if you got money, okay? You want to really
support the content, gift a couple subs. Every dollar goes towards
more time on the stream. We've got I think four subs for another
hour on the stream right now, okay? Exclamation boy donate in
the chat, we'll give you the links if you want to buy a TTS message.
Otherwise, you can gift kicks for TTS messages as well, okay?
Kicks are the big ones. Love kicks. We are 20 bucks four subs
or
2,000 kicks. Yeah, 2,000 kicks.
about Leo Convoy Nation and sorry, having sex with, not that
I condone that, but having sex with and murdering the wife of
your enemy. Uh just say what it is. You grade women on a morality
wait grade women on a morality curve. I literally don't know
what you're talking about. Yeah, but okay. It just feels dude,
it feels like you're so naive about this. You just think this
is no big nation and stalkers stronger together.
Let's go. Thank you very much, Pilkington. Appreciate the the
kicks, >> Aiden, you'll be fine.
I think I I I think I will be fine. Um ultimately, yeah. Well,
okay. I mean, let's define fine, I guess, if you I should I should
also say there's an element of which is inherently difficult
to deal with because it's subjective. I I try not to judge people
by their worst moments. When they're at their worst places in
life the in life, the actions they take, I try not to judge them
by that cuz I don't think that's broadly who they are as people.
I will say that's burned me on the internet several times now.
Might have to re-evaluate that. I do think in person that is
a good way to treat people.
On the internet, that's in fact burned me like several times
at this point. Might have to start revisiting. Might have to
start rethinking. >> to do that. Like my vision is that
you are going to be um you know, streaming to an ever decreasing
number of people that are just interested in your obsession with
Leo Convoy. All of our numbers are decreasing. It will stay at
the same rate as everyone like the of decrease everyone else
does.
But you know, This has actually caused a rise in my viewership,
the Leo show, which is like a greater incentive to keep covering
it. >> is the thing is when you okay,
when you say decreasing numbers, okay? Decreasing 10 or Oh, hello.
Hello.
Who is the little liar dude? Thank you for the sub. I think we
are two subs away from another hour on the stream.
>> makes a lot of difference when you're on 1,000 [snorts]
viewers versus 100 viewers, okay? And if that percentage point
hits a certain level, right? You can go to I mean, I don't know
what your financial situation is and I don't know if you wanted
to use this to support yourself in any way, but you know, it's
it's catastrophic in terms of money, it's catastrophic in terms
of like respect. People are not going to respect what you've
got to say or care what you've got to say.
Like I don't know, dude. This is to me this is catastrophic.
Being an art commentary community lolcow means that your only
purpose in life online is going to be is it possible to get a
rise out of Aiden projects because he spurts out a lot and he
does stupid stuff and talks about life through nation in a drunken
call. Yeah, they can try. I mean, I invite once again, I invite
anyone who disagrees to come on and try. Um I guess. Yeah. But
I think I'll be fine. Um I mean, I'm I'm I'm not going to beat
around the bush. Like I think what I did was like bad. I think
it was like uh I think it was I think it was like a mistake,
which is why this is like a one-off thing. Uh and I I I I know
>> Why would Why Okay, why would anyone believe this is
a one-off thing? Why? Why would someone believe that? Present
me with evidence that it is I mean, I don't know what to tell
you. It's just >> obviously, there's nothing There's no
proof I could provide, but I'm talking about the way that you
tried >> you want to just like make something up, yeah.
Like you like I I I can't respond to that. >> going to
make something up. I'm not going to make something up, okay?
The behavior that you're engaging in is antithetical to principles
that you would have stated even um you know, as recently as a
year ago, okay? But the screenshot that I saw
of you saying how gay it is to bring in third parties into dramas
that aren't involved. Yeah, I contradicted my own standards cuz
I was being impulsive and and like really dumb. >> Okay,
so you've already contradicted You've already contradicted your
own standards by being impulsive and dumb. Why would people believe
you're not going to do that again? >> Of course. Wait.
I saw Queen pull up a tweet from this guy earlier today. Who
is this person from Who is person just like a schizo?
He bought. You bought. Then don't even know. It was posted in
his private section, I see. Who is this person? Also, thank you
whoever just donated. Uh what I missed it. Hold on. Let me pull
up my dashboard. Uh Excel Rody, thank you for the gifted sub
to Chris Bledsoe. Let's
I saw someone pull up this guy's tweet. Who is this guy? He's
a He's a
a small YouTuber. Okay. I just like
I clearly know that it was posted in IC. I Okay. Whatever. Whatever,
man. >> Of course, that's why I admit it's >> But
you did it when you were drunk. So, the idea there is that you
were drunk and you didn't have as much control over your actions
and behavior. So, >> be held responsible, but I still could
be held
>> what I'm saying is you could get drunk again in the
future and you could be in a Discord call with your
to watch you and they're egging you on and egging you on and
egging you on. Before you know it, who knows what you're going
to do? You're going to send an email >> I'll just have
I'll just have to prove that I won't. Um and that if that that
well, it won't happen. I can tell you But people aren't going
to stick around for that. That's the point. Is you know, >> Then
then they don't have to. And like if I'm around 5 years from
now, they can keep bringing up that one-off incident from 5 years
ago and say it could happen again, but I can tell you it never
will cuz it was a mistake and I like to learn from mistakes.
Uh Aiden needs to understand though that it is like something
you'll have to grind through,
right? That it is You can get past it for sure. You can get past
like really bad things like reputational hits. I think I've had
some reputational hits. All you have to do, okay? This is all
you have to do. Have
Okay, persistently
consistently
exceed expectations. Just be better content than people expect
most of the time. Right? Like literally all you have to do is
be entertaining, be good at your job, come with like correct
information, help people like connect it in a way that's funny.
You do that consistently over time, you'll build back up your
Uh no, don't worry about it, Dirty Easy. But um
I I just think yeah, you just consistently show up. You just
consistently keep showing up. You do good content. You don't
get stuck spiraling on people criticizing you forever. Right?
You just show up. You do
better content than people expect and it'll be all good.
So, I guess time is just going to either prove one of us correct
>> I also don't like the way you treated Dickers either,
to be honest.
I don't know how I'm what my treatment of Dickers is like. Um
I mean, he's just like made stuff up about me, but Okay. Well,
my issue with the treatment of Dickers is when you talked about
this, I know what you were doing. It's very obvious. You got
into an intricate discussion about the definition of doxing because
you knew that you'd done wrong and you also knew and Dickers
knew that you had this private information about how deranged
you were acting on the call. You were trying to evade and escape
his scrutiny by being a debate
very obvious, very transparent. >> I was defensive because
I had him like I thought from my perspective and I agree this
might not be the case >> throw down a smoke bomb to escape
from Dickers' scrutiny so you didn't >> Okay, I mean, I
I don't know what you're looking at. I don't know what you're
looking for. I I could explain myself. I don't know if that's
what you're >> That's supposed to be your friend and you're
pulling debate tricks on him that makes him look bad now with
the context that's come out. You've made him look like a loser,
okay? Because he doesn't want to go hard at you. Yes, because
he doesn't want to go hard to you and rather than just admit
fault and at that point people don't know about the call, you
could have just said, "You know what? It was doxing and it was
bad." and moved on, okay?
I'll be honest, there's like 10 or 20% of me that was like I
still don't know enough of like the information here. I didn't
want to get in that call. That like I I think Beckett was telling
me to get in. He's like, "Just join. Just join. We'll drag you.
Get in." and I'm like, "Nah."
What I I'll drop I'll jam the content, but it's like I I don't
want to I don't think I can hold Aiden to task without hearing
like more information about like what I need to go and get leaked
to me like what he said in IC where everything was from and stuff,
right?
Like what explicitly he had said cuz I knew he leaked the the
doxing IC. I just didn't know like what explicitly was said,
what explicitly was leaked. Anyway, so I I do I and I feel like
I didn't want to be the guy who showed up and then didn't press
Aiden the proper
You know? You're just You're just You've gone into the debate
mode in order to >> You've gone into the debate file mode
in order to escape scrutiny, okay? Knowing what you know about
the call. >> myself here. I'm wrong. Okay, but you weren't
with Dickers, were you? I was I cuz you know, I just I just admitted
it to you. You don't respect Dickers. That's what it is. It's
>> It has nothing to do with my Okay, that's just like
I I've literally said to Dickers apparently he's saying I respect
you and Queen and over him and he knows that's not true because
we've had like private hearts. I mean, Just different kinds of
respect, man. It's obviously different kinds of respect where
Aiden against his own judgment will agree with Queen or Chud.
Aiden would never against his own judgment agree with Dickers.
And we can see that because Dickers repeatedly a thousand different
times said, "Aiden, get the off this call. Aiden, stop doing
this. Aiden, stop. Aiden, stop. Aiden, stop. Aiden, stop." He
was nice. He was mean. He was nice. He was mean.
But Aiden would hear like Queen tell him to stop and his ears
would perk up like the It'd be like the Oh, wait. No. Queen is
there, too. So, he would be like a golem, okay? Getting directions
from the master. He would just immediately like
In a way that he wouldn't for Dickers,
Uh you might want to say that instead of respect, it's fear.
That could be what it is, right? But there is something there
where Aiden would totally stop if Queen told him to stop and
when Dickers tells him to stop, he feels like he can argue with
Dickers.
So, there's respect. Like I'm sure he wouldn't just like disrespect
Dickers to his face, but it's a It's a different kind of >> is
[__] house and [__] >> Dickers,
why didn't you say to him, "Do you know what, mate? You got me
bang to rights. It was doxing and I shouldn't have done it and
I won't do it again." >> Because I was being hyper defensive
because I felt like people are coming at me from all directions
over separate that was being invoked. People would bring up like
my private like what they assumed to be like were private relationships
and stuff, which was causing drama behind the scenes and I honestly
just wasn't like I honestly was just being hyper defensive and
like a little bit nervous >> much, [laughter] bro, why
didn't you knock off for a bit? Stop using this pressure that
you >> I mean, yeah, that's that's like great that's like
great hunt That's like good advice in hindsight. I like admit
I made a mistake. Um yeah. Okay. I don't know the exact word
to describe it. I feel like mistake doesn't really do just justice
to the catastrophic destruction that you've wrought. >> I'm
minimizing this. Well, yeah. Because uh you could call it a mistake,
right? I mean, getting drunk and running someone over could be
a mistake, right? [laughter] But that doesn't mean >> holocaust
I've committed. Like I don't know like what you're looking for
from it. Like it was a mistake. I I I was bad. It was really
bad. Well, the difficulty is I've got a perception of how it's
going to go from here and you were just insistent that this is
no big deal. And I'm pointing out people like Flamenco and you're
acting like, "Oh, well, something else happened that actually
led to the destruction of Flamenco, okay?" But the thing is the
Zand stuff
Is Beckett also known as Dickers? Yes. It's the same person.
Not many people know that. But yeah. Um you'll never see the
two YouTube channels running at the same time. >> wanted
to secede and the only reason he was able to successfully wiggle
out of that is because Augie was willing to give him the benefit
of the doubt and sweep for him. Who is going to sweep for
Um nobody I I I'm not planning on it. I'm going to I'm going
to own up to it and I'm just not going to repeat it. Um and I
I mean, if you're right, you're going to get to If you care,
you're going to get to say I told you so, but it's not going
to happen. >> I'm Dude, I'm not intro Yeah, I'm probably
you know,
I [laughter] was about to say something really harsh then. I
also said something really harsh. I don't give a [__]
about what happens with you from here on out, to be honest, right?
There is some
This is the way it went. Yes, exactly.
Aiden's like, "I don't really think it's that bad." He's like,
"You are an art commentary community. Lolcow, Aiden." Aiden's
like, "Okay, I guess." "Aiden, you are finished. You're literally
Flamenco, bro. You are literally Flamenco, bro."
Okay, I got Yes. There was some latent like, you know, obviously,
we I don't know I don't know how you stop this where it's just
you just keep restating the same things over and over again.
I have this problem, too, sometimes. Like I'm pretty sure I'm
correct.
We've been chill. Like, I don't like hate you necessarily. I
also said it really harsh. I don't give a [__] about
what happens with you from here on out, to be honest, right?
There is some There is some latent, like, you know, obviously,
we've been chill. Like, I don't like hate you necessarily, right?
I don't hate you. So, I don't want bad stuff to happen to you
necessarily. I don't want you to like die, obviously, right?
But, to me, it's like it's just a shame. It's tragic. It's like
you [__] yourself over for the sake of obsessing
about an ACC loser for the entertainment of 100 Discord chat
that don't actually know how to do this. Yeah, sure. It is It
is a shame. And once again, uh it's it's, you know, it's wrong.
It's a mistake. Do you have any apologies you'd like to give
at this point to anyone? To To Lyle's wife. Sure. For what?
I'm I'm sorry for spreading your information with you First of
all, obviously, there's no nothing you could really do that would
justify me doing that. But, second of
there was nothing you've done, like, period. Uh So, like, I There's
it was it bringing in a third party was a contradiction of my
own standards. Okay. So, you think it was wrong to bring in a
third party into this, right?
Yes, and I contradicted my own standard. Yep. So, you've also
wronged Leo Convoy, haven't you? Haven't you, by your own
Sure, you know. Okay. So,
to Leo Convoy now. I'm sorry, Lyle. I'd love to give them the
apology voice to voice. Is he down to call him by chance?
Go on. What have you got to say for yourself? Is Chad talking
to his child or something? Why is he demanding apologies from
this young boy? Uh there's been this whole drama with Aiden.
If you haven't been watching the Agent Aiden Project drama, so
I pants, then you're you're you're missing out, okay? You're
missing out majorly if you haven't been following it. It's been
pretty good.
Um Chad is chastising this guy who doxxed some
some, like, Lyle Cow's wife that he was following and realistically
broke a ton of his own principles. He deserves chastisement.
That's why he's doing it. Lyle, I'm I'm so I'm sorry, Lyle. I'm
Sorry, I'd love to talk Oh, the technical issues. How convenient.
Wait, what happened? What happened?
>> just You were just issuing your heartfelt apology to
Lyle Convoy. Please continue. Oh, no. Sorry, sorry, sorry. What
I was just saying There's like this action button on the iPhone.
What I was just saying was um I I'm sorry. I'm sorry to Lyle,
and I'd love to say my apologies in a conversation on stream.
He can feel free to call in. Okay.
And there's one final person that you've hurt because I had to
cut you off >> I know what you want. You're not getting
it. What, Dickers?
Oh, no. I thought you were talk I thought you were talking about
someone
No, no, not really. I mean, not that I can think of specifically.
Um I mean, if it's the Perry, I mean, I don't really give a [__]
about Perry. No, I thought you were talk I thought you were talking
about held that for a second. I was like, yeah, you're not getting
that. Um I mean, look, at the end of the day, we can get I maybe
I just don't understand Chad's
Cuz like, if the other stuff were true, I don't get the like
tone now.
Maybe I just don't understand him as a person. That's possible.
Right? The The tone now feels totally disconnected from your
credibility's
You have nowhere to go left to go. You'll never grow as a creator.
You'll never ever like It's like, okay, so you were being hyperbolic
intentionally there just to state the maximal.
It's all fatherly.
It's that one stuff. Come on. Dickers deserves an apology, too.
Come on. You've kind of [__] him around, haven't
you? Let's be real. You know Is this same Chad that said you
swept for Nick Lee?
Yeah, I I'm I'm sorry. I'm I'm sorry for I'm sorry for frustrating
Dickers, who's very genuine to me behind the scenes and in front
of the scenes. Um and uh he's been nothing but genuine and kind.
And uh he didn't deserve He didn't deserve that. Okay. Okay.
Um there's a few other details to get to here, okay? >> I
I'm I'm I'm interested in like talking about the nature of your
content because, you know, I've heard that you focus on Leo Convoy
a lot. I've heard that you, you know, like to have kind of obsess
over him and stuff. What's the appeal? Why do you want to cover
him so Maybe this is what happened. Yeah, maybe this is what
Um because I think he's a horrible person, but I also think he's
a really embarrassing and funny person. If you listen to the
way he talks and behaves, um I get viewership from doing it.
I get increased dollars doing it. Um so, like, in terms of any
sort of career incentive, that exists. And it's a topic I'm just
like personally uh vested in, right? Um I I have a vested interest
in. Okay. Like, there's no downsides. I'm I'm interested in the
subject.
Okay. Because my belief that I was kind of expressing earlier
is you have kind of like done this thing where you've started
to cover Lyle, and it's like a feedback loop where some of the
worst, most [__] toxic [__] watch you,
and then it becomes a cycle. You feed them the Leo Convoy content,
and they provoke you to engage in the behavior that you've engaged
in, which I think is why it's gotten this bad.
And I don't think I I can see maybe why you see that. I I don't
think I've been providing This has been by my I'm like I I mean,
to be honest, like, I'm going to sound like it's going to sound
gay cuz like empathy or whatever, but like uh I just I have a
I have like a soft spot or whatever for like uh for like mentally
vulnerable adults who are like, you know, like probably the same.
I I don't know. I can't get people like into this drama.
I actually
Dude, I'm looking at like my metrics cuz I was just thinking,
like, why am I covering Aiden right now? I think it's cuz I'm
obsessed with like this drama. I think my metrics are literally
like
shockingly better.
Shockingly better just doing politics. I get so much more engagement
covering
It's actually really funny.
I've been down bad for a quick rundown for days. Well, I've given
uh like 100 different quick rundowns. You just haven't been here
any of the times, Chinese agent. He um He doxxed somebody. He's
getting made fun of for doxxing people. I watched it all and
came back cuz it was too slow, lol. Okay.
Oh, all right. I don't know why you came back to say that. Still
going through the same phase.
Oh, I was just kind of mid. No, I think
I think it's just like the engagement. I get I think a lot of
other people I have a lot of fun, yeah. But, I think a lot of
people do like the politics content like way more. It's It's
just surprising to me cuz usually drama's way better. But, it
might be that like because I share overlapping community with
all of these other communities, it might be that other people
just want to go to the people who are there, like, Dickers or
Queen might get more engagement over this specific drama because
they were involved, right? When I first heard Lyle's call with
Frozo, which is kind of infamous, I just started I had a hatred
of this individual kind of one. And then when I heard his apology
and then Dickers sweeping, it got worse. Sure, okay. And tell
me a bit about how Leo Convoy treated this person called uh Goat
Katto. Apparently, there was like something hosted in Okay. All
right. I thought it was over the top. I think um Aiden sort of
stuff. I thought Maybe if Chad just thought he needed to hear
this that like Maybe that's Maybe that's what Chad's doing here
is he's he's saying this only in a way that you know, people
need to hear this to maybe course correct or something.
If this drama was even a YouTuber with 100K, it would pop would
have popped off. Yeah, maybe.
Honestly, I'll be real. Um
for me personally, the doxxing stuff seems like really, really,
really
like not
It seems like obvious in a way that
I think sort of It's just like
The relationship stuff was what was funny to me and calling Aiden
like a weirdo's pet. So, that was what was funnier to me.
Go to the last 4 minutes of this of this stream or of the call?
Yeah, I'm like kind of tapped. Like,
whatever now.
Like, once Perry leaves, basically.
The calls were horrendous. Yeah, sure. >> I just stated
that I like this person. I feel things for them. And I had conceded
to what Dickers said. And I shouldn't cuz I was wrong. Is there
a way to make this stop? But, then I believe it was came up.
And uh so, it's sort of sort of like here. So, you were talking
to him. Uh you just
Literally, where did he find a microphone this bad? Where do
you even find a microphone this bad?
Oh, the leaked Discord stuff?
Yeah, I I guess I just disagree, Gringo. I like I disagree only
along the lines of I think Aiden doing the whole thing about
this guy's wife, it's just him being drunk and trying to be edgy
in a Discord. He's like a weird He's trying to be edgy in a Discord.
That's it. To me.
It's It's all the stuff before that. And then you try to connect
it and say, "No, I think this is all real." It's like, "No, I
don't think so." I think it looks worse, but it like
I don't know. It I see such a clear I see such a clear reason
for why he was talking like that. And again, when when they start
participating, when the people in the Discord start
that's when it gets bad to me.
Sure, but normal people don't do that. No. Don't do what? Don't
joke about
Yeah, but like that's sort of what this entire community was
built on, no? >> It's like you keep making stuff up, so
I don't really
Uh I don't know what to say. You lied as well. You lied in Chad's
chat, but I know your last name. I have you on WhatsApp. Your
last name is not You don't know my last name, idiot. I've never
When have I ever seen your
Go that far with jokes?
It's not about going that far with a joke. Everybody laughed
at Perry going super far with the absurdest jokes. That's Aiden
trying to do absurdest jokes with no imagination.
He's drunk. He's trying to do absurdest humor just like Perry
would do, but he doesn't have the imagination, so it doesn't
land.
Last name. I said to me, "Your last My WhatsApp Apparently, this
is good around here. Should go watch this Aiden >> the
L. It was my fault. It was my fault. This is the relevant clip.
My apologies. You great evidence You want to join the call? Not
like woman Obviously. Uh can you substantiate that? Do we really
want to go into the
the details of between you and GoKato. >> Yeah, there's
there's there's no there's no details, right? I I know you >> Okay.
guys keep playing >> Did you tell GoKato that you loved
her? Yes. Sorry, what was that Aiden? Um >> But I was wrong
and I was wrong then. I told her I loved her. >> What?
So you were
I was wrong. I told her I liked her.
that's why that's why I actually at the end of the day probably
can't even be mad at Chud for just like this guy and not letting
him talk and not letting him weasel out of stuff cuz like I was
wrong. I told her I liked her.
>> but you're telling the truth now.
Yeah, I never Well, I was wrong then.
from this point, dude. It's over, dude. It's never been more
over, dude. So right, let me get dude, okay.
That's It's unfortunate cuz Aiden just walked into the exact
criticism I've been making the whole time, right? Like precisely
he walked into it. Precisely. You have clearly changed your story
tiny bit by tiny bit as more information has come out. That is
obviously
weird to do. That you you could say I'm not going to talk about
it, but then you put like a little bit out and you change your
story every single time more information comes out. That you
lie maximally for what you think you can get away with.
And you've like shown it off pretty substantially throughout
this whole >> Let me get this straight, right? You're coming
in here, dude. You are such a disgusting, wretched piece of [__]
low brow. It's unbelievable. >> offended by this. You you
little
Shut the [__] up, you pathetic gay. >> It's
going to be okay, man. It's going to be okay. >> total
loser.
Okay? You will lie with what you think you can get away with.
Okay. Okay, finally. Yes!
This is what I was saying. This is the thing you should actually
get angry about. This is the thing you should actually get it
No, hold on. I see people in Chud's chat soapbox is here sometimes.
Chud is being performative here. No, he's not. This is actually
the worst This Dude, I almost I understand the doxing is worse.
There's harm that's done. But this is like the kind of thing
that I'm like, "Oh, get the [__] away from me." Like
what are you doing? Get the [__] away. Like dude,
that you'll just lie about everything for as much as you can
as long as you can. Like the whole purpose of a lot of this stuff
of like debating with people, of talking about [__]
like this is that we're all operating under the rule of that
like you have to be about as truthful as you can be or else like
you could just lie about everything and be really good at debating
because you lie, right? It isn't lying if you just say it was
a mistake. Um you could just say it was a mistake, but Aiden
was obviously Aiden in his response to this clip literally showed
that he was lying. He goes, "Well, actually I didn't say I loved
her. I said I liked her."
And it's like what do you think you're talking about? It's about
you having a crush on this person. It's about you having wanting
a relationship with this person. That's what it's about. So when
you say I didn't say I loved her, actually I said I liked her.
It's like, "Dude, you are you are lying about the substance of
everybody's concern
with a technicality and it is it starts to become it's so annoying.
By the way, he could have easily said from the very beginning
with all of this stuff, he could have easily said, "I'm not talking
about GoKato stuff. I'm not talking about that that off you want
to talk about that, right?"
He could have easily done this. In 5 minutes prior to this clip
playing, he told Chud he denied saying he loved GoKato and called
Perry a liar on the call. Oh, yeah, well unfortunately Helbent
came in to my chat yesterday or the day before and explicitly
said that it was a lie. Explicitly said, "No, you're wrong."
Aiden, you told Bean Queeny you were in love with her at the
at the dinner we went to the Italian restaurant. That's not even
confusing, bro. What are we talking about here? >> will
lie about what you think you can get away with, okay? So right,
I've figured it out now. You lied to Dickers and you lied to
everyone else about the doxing [__] and you manipulate
and you debate, bro. And then you're exposed for >> No,
I did I I I didn't say I loved her. I said I liked her. >> act
all apologetic about it, okay? And you act you say you're sorry
and stuff like that. And now you're lying about this cuz you
think you can get away with >> No, the wording of the there's
no there's no there's no lie
because you know that I'm not covering this or So why are you
now changing the story again? You changed the story when you
think you can get away with it. >> I'm sorry.
When like you get details that show that an original statement
was wrong, you should revise it. I mean I know like the I know
the words like kind of
make sense. So we have to like I guess mark them, but no like
when you learn to when you
Look, when I look at these DMs cuz this did happen quite some
time ago, I just told her that I liked her or that I like feelings
for her or something. I'd never said to her that I loved her
and that's what I admitted to you on this stream, right? So there
there isn't a lie. Dude, I'm so over with this guy, man. It's
so
why did he wreck himself this badly at the end of the call? Why
did he do this? Why did he Why? Why the [__] would
you do this? It's so stupid. >> Let's finish up with the
DMs. She's full permission. If she disputes that or anything,
she just leak it, right? So what I showed him was like Oh, it's
a screenshot from my stream. Oh, let's go.
Oh, it's a
embarrassing for me. >> So one of the other guys had he
told me and Queeny at the restaurant he was in love with her.
Okay, the claim is what I said to The claim is what I said to
her. I didn't dis I just said I don't remember >> you So
I told her I liked her and I told everybody else I was in love
with her, but I never said to her that I loved
Okay. say that and now you're saying you didn't say that. What's
the difference for the What's the reason for the >> say
what's Because this happened a long This happened a while ago
where I had This was like months ago, I think, right? I confided
feelings. I don't remember exactly the nature of what I had stated,
um but I just like >> the voice crack?
Okay. I I just stated like that I just stated that I like this
person I had feelings for them and I had conceded to a Dickers
said and I shouldn't cuz I was wrong in the first clip and then
when you learn you're wrong cuz information you should revise
your position. That's like a good thing to do. >> it's
it's self-reported. So you realized you were wrong and that you
didn't say that you loved her. No, I didn't. I just I I said
that I had feelings. Okay. So what Okay, explain to me then.
No, this is [__] Dude, I've just
Yeah, please don't please don't give this away.
When you're talking about this, the whole reason it's being brought
up, the reason he's disputing it, he's disputing it on a detail
when the substance of the statement 100% goes against him and
he's not making it clear that he knows that the substance of
the thing he's disputing is true while the particulars of it
are false, right? You can say I want to make an correction even
though the substance is true and you can do
But But what you can't do is go, "Well,
Hey, man, I've heard that you went on like a serial killer spree
from 1979
to 1998. Is that true? No, it's false. I went on a serial killer
spree from 1979 to 1997." Like but not not including that second
part, just saying no, that's false. It's like, "Well, technically
I probably could concern that you're a serial killer who went
on a killer spree for multiple decades."
But what you're saying is no, that's false when it's like technically
false, but the broad
the broad [snorts] brush of it, the broad strokes are true. And
he's trying to do that here in a way that's very obvious, very
very easy to call out. And he seems to have done it multiple
times through this. Again, the Willy Mac stuff I guess would
probably be a good >> on the base again and telling me
it's not If this doesn't make sense to you,
No, I'm not You're a lying
wretch. You're
>> escape anything that might make you look bad cuz you're
talking You're You're You're just found information that provides
my You are proven conclusively that you're slippery little you,
okay? Dude, if you were not Germany, you'd have slipped away
from the [__] SS because of how slippery you are.
>> like the performative like fake anger [__]
the morality
No, I don't think you should be performative like this is actually
This is somebody treating you like a you're a right? This is
somebody lying to you. It This is actually the problem here,
This is like the problem is obvious that he he is lying tangibly
in a way that he has slight possible deniability for, but nothing
else. >> Guess what, you stupid That's called being entertaining,
you Yeah,
stream which is garbage already. It's going to fail, bro. You
are done. Well, one of the accusations client killer. So Leo
Convoy and his community had a drama with GoKato where GoKato
was wronged and Aiden did commentary on that, apparently talked
to GoKato and then started like DMing with GoKato. She became
a part of his community. Okay?
So Aiden had defended her and then met met GoKato, defended her
and and had her slide into the community at that point and then
continued to go after this Lyle Convoy person and a lot of people
are alleging that he went after Lyle Convoy because of a relationship
with GoKato that he became like obsessed because of that.
And so he says no. >> wretch. You're exposed multiple times
for being a lying wretch. You're done, bro. You're >> Okay.
So
you either lying then or you're lying
No, there wasn't a lie that was I got some I got a detail wrong
and that's like not like a major
major detail to get wrong. I had I'd confessed feelings to somebody
months ago and the specific word that I'd used to confide those
feelings and when I was asked about it and didn't have the DMs
pulled up at that point in time, I'd used the wrong word, a word
that would make me look more embarrassing. So I don't know why
I would lie and admit to that. And then when I go back to the
specific DMs, I realized that wasn't the word I used and I've
revised it accordingly, right?
Okay, that's all fine. Now I feel like I have to go back. Ryan,
could you find me the timestamp for further back where it comes
up because the context in which it comes up is important, right?
If he said, "No, I didn't tell her I loved her. I just expressed
my feelings. I said I liked her." If that's what he said, then
he's fine.
Is Goat Cato some kind of double furry? Ironically, yes. Yes.
Yeah, I Yes. Yeah, you're pretty much nailing it. I believe a
furry character made from a goat and a cat. You You think you're
just Sweatpants Freedom asked this question and he thinks he's
like He thinks he's just making it up, but actually
No, I believe it is like a hybrid of a goat and a cat with the
goat horns and then the furry cat body. So, you thought you were
You thought you were like making fun of this person, making something
up, but no. You want it from the Dicker stream? No, I want the
Chud stream where they ask him about it. Where they like bring
it up.
Like what however far we have to go >> Um and that's what
you should do when you get new information on a position or on
a take that you give them. >> I think this is like some
debate that you're doing. I think this No, that's just common
sense. I think that you know, if I hadn't have had that clip,
you would have tried to weasel and worm around it, but then when
the clip is presented, oh no, it is different, but then you said
that >> There's no weasel Doxing thing. Exactly, not the
doxing thing. And this is your problem. You cannot just admit
fault. I No, no, I was I'm sorry, I just said I was wrong. If
that's not like admitting fault to you, then like you're like
daft. I don't know what to say. I just said I was wrong in the
first iteration of the So, like what? Did you forget that you
said on stream the other day that you loved her then?
Uh I didn't remember using that word, but hearing it, that was
inaccurate in the DM that >> Surely, if there was a difference,
you'd say, "Oh no, I did say that I loved her, but actually da
da da da." Instead, you flatly denied it until I showed you incontrovertible
proof of you at least saying it. Yeah, and that would be a weird
thing to lie about cuz in that case it would make me look Okay,
we got a timestamp for where this started. worse. Actually, da
da da da. Instead, you flatly denied it
>> Okay, Chud's making the exact
the exact allegation >> be a weird thing to lie about cuz
in that case it would make me look worse, right? Um I just checked
I did I got asked about it on a stream. I didn't have the DMs
up. This was months ago. And we wouldn't click the send button
cuz we don't care, okay? Aiden, did you or did you not
say to the group that you love Goat Cato, yes or no? Don't think
I did. Oh, what was that? You don't think you did? Well, that's
not so certain, is >> I don't remember. I've never told
her that I loved her. Okay, so you All right, you're reaffirming
back that point there, right? I think that means that you did
tell the group. You did tell the group.
So, he's And this is the thing. Again, I don't quite know why
he's asking this. It just might be to prove Aiden's like weasel-iness,
but this is the thing is
he could say
"Well, I've never told her that. I did describe feelings. I talked
to the group about feelings. So, while love might not have been
the word and it makes me look like a loser if you say love, more
of a loser than I already look, I did describe feelings. I did
express
Then then you can't really call him a liar here, right?
But he doesn't want to say that. And in fact, okay, I'm getting
confirmation here that you did indeed tell the group that you
love Goat Cato, okay? The The claim that I denied was that I've
ever
said that to her. It doesn't matter what the exact detail of
it is, okay? Whether or not you said it to her Okay, of course
you changed
the claim. Okay, the claim is not okay. The distinction is not
meaningful because whether or not you said it to her, you were
in love with her and you tried to get her with your approach
and she rejected you. >> Yeah, I'm some like Yeah, I'm
like some 20-year-old like social awkward like loser that like
had interest in like a girl. If that's like what you like feel
like is worth covering,
I mean, that's like good for you, but I kind of feel like that
like is kind of weird. >> stream on my day off, okay? Right?
Yeah, there's legitimately nothing better to
Uh he says that. I don't know why Chud hasn't shilled this entire
stream. It doesn't look like he's making very much in in Kick
donations.
Um
I think he almost hit like a thousand viewers with this content.
That would have been a That was a big Kick stream. He makes so
much money from this Kick stream. Well, I could talk about the
eye shooting again, but I'm getting kind of bored of talking
about that, okay? And the thing is, it's not about the details
of the relationship, it's about how wretched you are for desperately
trying to obtain this art commentary person whilst they're thirsty
and they're If it's your day off, why don't you go get like a
coffee with some woman? Like why don't you go go like get in
a relationship? >> difference is I keep the nature of my
interactions private because at the end of the day, it's not
anyone's business, but you have put yourself in a position >> and
if you're telling people in confidence, they they I hope I would
hope that they don't tell people like they do me, right?
No, I think he's saying he doesn't like let people know.
Well, yeah, but that's a product of you trusting Parry, which
is cuz Parry is a totally untrustworthy freak from the sounds
of it. I'm trustable. I'm trustable. Just don't lie to >> that
reflects like worse on him.
Maybe don't be flirtatious to me next time, Aiden, when we talk
about this.
>> Why didn't you have a single complaint
Maybe don't be mean to me next time. >> I used the wrong
word. I've looked back in the DMs and I've revised it accordingly.
That makes total sense. If it doesn't, then there's like something
wrong with you. No, it doesn't make sense. What makes It Again,
I I don't know if Aiden has to get clubbed upside the head, okay?
Maybe this is just a high IQ thing where he can't he can't accept
any statement from anybody unless it's 100% accurate, but it's
like bro, the problem here is when we ask if you expressed that
you love this woman and you told the group you love this woman
and you say, "No, I don't I don't I didn't. No, I I don't believe
I did. No, I didn't tell her that." It's like it's moving in
a direction that is away from the truth.
Cuz the truth is you expressed that you want a relationship with
her and you told the group that you're pining for this person.
Makes more sense is you will lie to protect your reputation.
>> You will lie to protect your reputation, okay? And then
when that lie is exposed, you'll come up with some other reason
or excuse for it. Exactly >> where's the doxing stuff?
Do you want the You tried to downplay the doxing stuff originally.
>> want me to Do you want me to send you the DM? Do you
want me to send you the DM to prove that that wasn't my word
was not love. The word was like that I had feelings. I don't
care about the exact >> Wait, you don't care to get to
get shown you're wrong. I get that. It I he's getting defiant
about it. Uh this is the worst part. This is the worst thing
that does. It's so absurd.
It's so absurd.
Uh what's up, Queen and Raiders? Thank you very much for the
raid, Queen. What's up? What's up? What's up, guys?
I just realized now that Queen raided that I've not been in my
Discord. I should probably join that in case anybody wanted to
come in and comment on
Not just Queen, but anybody. Hop back in Uh Jesus Christ, man.
How does How does Aiden do it? How does he make himself the most
unlikable person every single time? Every single time. >> It
doesn't look good to to be wrong, but like I'm admitting I'm
wrong. I think you should probably do the same thing. Yeah, I
just like
uh I was I used the wrong word off of memory and I've revised
it accordingly and I admit I was wrong in So, for the raid people
who just got raided in, we just got to the point in the conversation
where Aiden is asked point-blank, "Did you say you love this
woman? Did you tell the group that you were with that you love
this woman?" And he goes, "I don't I don't think so." See the
part where Chud was skin-walking Pisco against Dickers? Um probably.
Uh so
he says Aiden says, "No, I don't think I said it to them and
I definitely didn't say it to her." And says nothing else,
Now, if somebody asked you some question like this, okay? If
somebody asked you a question like
Hey, did did this happen? And you again, we'll do the serial
killer example, okay? Were you a serial killer in California
from the years 1979 to 1998?
You go, "No, I wasn't."
And in your mind you say, "Well, that's okay to say that because
I was actually a serial killer during the years of 1979
and 1997."
You're obviously
lying.
The
It is obviously they are misconstruing a slight detail
that allows you to say, "No, that's not technically true." While
avoiding the fact that the entirety of like the the actual meaning
of the statement, the question they asked, the the thing they're
saying is true, the entirety of it. 99.9% of it is true. The
entirety of the weight of, "Hey Aiden, were you talking to these
people about your personal like obsession with this woman or
or that you're pining for this woman and did you Were you Did
you express feelings to her?" That's all true. I've asked the
same question.
So, if it's a tiny semantic detail like that by which you're
escaping and saying, "No, you're totally wrong." then it is incumbent
on you to correct.
Right? Or to say Or you could say, "I don't want to talk about
this."
Right? You could say, "I'm not going to talk about this. It's
private. I'm not going to talk about it." so easily.
But what Aiden does is he said, "No." And then he has the audacity,
okay? The audacity
to tell Chud, "No, you're actually wrong. No, you're actually
wrong. No, you're actually wrong. No, you're actually wrong.
No, you're actually wrong. No, isn't it embarrassing for you
right now, Chud?" He's doing this whole thing. "I know it's embarrassing
for you, Chud, that you're wrong. I know it's like super embarrassing.
You're embarrassed now that you're like totally wrong about this."
And it's like, "Dude, you are
you're taking anybody who could possibly defend you and you're
giving them every reason in the world to just pray on your downfall.
I do not understand why you're My word was not love. The word
was like that I had feelings. I don't care about the exact DMs.
>> Wait, you don't care to get to get shown you're wrong.
I get that. It It doesn't look good to to be wrong, but like
I'm admitting I'm wrong. I think you should probably do the same
thing. Yeah, I just like
uh I was I get used the wrong word off of memory and I've revised
it accordingly and I admit I was wrong in the first >> that
you did with Dickers. It's the same
bro. You're doing this
when the broad thrust of what I'm saying is still true. Oh, responding
to your arguments. Responding to your arguments. I I guess that's
awkward to you. I don't know what to tell you. Stop skim walking
Destiny. You'll be felching. Come out of the closet. >> like
a bizarre crash right now. I'm not having a bizarre crash at
all, dude. I'm not having a bizarre crash at all. It's not bizarre.
It's because you're a lying wretch and your credibility is everything
you've done
Is this
I feel like probably Destiny does do this. I don't think it's
like this one is a thing he's known for cuz I think he's called
people out for it. Yeah, everybody will I I think nearly everybody
will do this sometimes, but Aiden just has been doing it consistently
through this whole thing. It's like the I want to say I can't
say this for sure, okay? He might be he might get pedantic on
me. I feel like this is like time he's done it. I feel like he's
done it so many [__] times at this point. It's absurd.
No, I Sorry, when I said anybody, I meant anybody with perms
to my Collins channel. Anybody who's got like a notable tag in
my Discord critical rod. I'm not taking general conversation.
>> destroyed and ruined your credibility.
>> you could keep saying that. I I don't I don't know what
to tell you. I respectfully disagree.
You're just like a little wretched snake slithering about the
place hoping you won't get exposed for one thing after the other.
So true. That's why I've admitted I was wrong like several times.
Yeah, it makes total sense. Yeah, I don't know what to tell you,
bro. I'm I mean like I don't know if you're just keeping this
up cuz you have nothing else. Um, but I >> I've got other
stuff I can talk about,
Cheers. But uh, you know, I mean, there's not I mean, the reality
is there's not really much to say, bro. Further than yes, you're
totally wretched ACC local. You've turned into the beast that
you were fighting >> you said that. Do you have like any
other like this Are you limited in your descriptors? You've used
like the same like word like about eight million
Hold on. Is Aiden about to make a
ACC local, flamenco, can you actually make an argument or are
you just going to sperg? I Dude, it'd be very funny. He's not
going to win ultimately because he's just been like a lying wretch
for the entire conversation. Well, for a large part of the all
these conversations.
He's not going to win, but he does have a point that Chud is
Chud is harping on the same same exact like qualifiers or or
or labels the whole time. It it's like Well, isn't it? You've
got too close to the abyss and you've got to stop >> but
I don't I don't want to say it cuz you just like repeat yourself
in like loop on like the same like sentence, right? If you have
something new, we could talk about it. Um Yeah, I don't know
what to tell you.
Have you guys been on, I don't know, an emotionally complicated
I've never to No, I've never been in a situation to answer the
question, honestly. No, there's no
I I'm I'm I'm I'm >> said that you were fine with this
being discussed about why she's on your side rather than mine.
>> did I
Dude, Aiden is so Aiden needs to work on this more than anything
else in debates, okay? When you're uncomfortable, don't immediately
go to 1 HP voice. Bro, that was crazy. No, there's no
I I'm I'm I'm I'm >> said that you were fine with this
Dude, that that That was crazy.
That was insane
like
age regression. I'm just a little baby, don't hurt me. It's like
It's that's a crazy thing to do in the middle of like a contentious
debate with somebody. That was wild, okay? >> about why
she's on your side rather than mine. No, no, no, no, no, no.
say I was fine Okay, I don't know why people are telling me to
play more of this. This is [__] worthless, bro.
Oh, that was pretty funny the 1 HP voice, though. Yeah, I mean,
you know, I think that
that's about it, really. I don't think there's much more to discuss
here.
All right, fair enough.
Good. Take care. Peace. I think that's why Aiden's taking this
route because he knows no one in this scene is going to [__]
with him like that anymore. And arguing this way is the only
way to make sure he can still do this long term. Kind of.
Kind of. I I think people will [__] with him. I think
if he consistently like performs, if he's consistently doing
like good content, if he finds good content and he like basically
is the person who's like putting his flag in it at first, like
I don't think this ends his career. I think that's absurd.
I think that's really hyperbolic. Ultimately, it's not like he
published this stuff broadly. It's not like he um Like it's it's
bad. It's bad enough that he should like take a hit for it. But
like it's not it's not in the worst possible way and I've seen
people who do this in the worst possible way take like not that
significant a hit to their careers. So, yeah.
Maybe maybe people are saying that they think this was just Chud
trying to break his ego saying this over and over again. I guess
so.
Any example of what I just think you could keep streaming through
stuff and it's not a problem.
That's how I That's how I feel about it.